[Music]
say
sh
[Music]
w
n
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
you
he
[Music]
I like
bir
[Music]
w
a
[Music]
don't
man
[Music]
oh
welcome to the final day of the puzzle
World Championship here on chess.com I
am joining the broadcast because hey
you've already seen this guy before he
was here yesterday I'm with my friend
James KY what's up James you ready for
today man we ready bro it's the finals
chat Get Hype it's the finals it's going
down today you're going to see some epic
puzzle battle runs today so I'm excited
it was a lot of action yesterday Aman
you missed it unless you was watching of
course but it was definitely exciting so
yeah I I was following along I was
following along but I don't think I had
the front row seat much like you did but
I think you're going to have to catch me
up James because yesterday was crazy
there were so many people competing and
ultimately we Whitted it down to eight
players but tell me James what did I
miss you missed uh well first off it was
like one off there somebody said have
just join to make 100 participants 99
it's just rude my bad my bad thank you
thank you it's all good you're here
today but it was 4,000 minutes of course
how many minutes in a day guys that's
ridiculous all that chest plate there it
was a
22500 puzzle rushes there and then
76,000 puzzles solved have you ever done
that many puzzles in your life is the
question there and that was just
yesterday no is the answer there uh def
definitely not I mean we had so much so
much action yesterday but it's all about
the finals today so let's take a look
James at who is actually still in this
competition with a chance to win let's
bring up the bracket and we can see here
a lot of names very familiar to the folk
here of course Ray Robson but I'm
looking at these names some some new
names for me in this competition James
anything stand out in terms of a a match
you're excited for or a player to watch
man definitely the player to watch and
match to be excited for if is really the
man Andy the kid up there of course a
man it's he's actually kid in fact a
teenager uh Andy Woodward there actually
was a menace yesterday 59 he broke a
high but also yesterday last night in
fact as we were streaming Andy Woodward
with a username wacky Hill on Twitch
comes into the chat and he's like hey
I'm playing Ray right now so we sto what
we're doing automatically you know put
the kids to bed and we watch Andy play
Ray Robinson in Puzzle Battle last night
they were going back and forth and then
also Ray was able to win some games but
the fact that they were up last night
fighting is crazy to see see if I mean
I'm excited to see what happens if if
Andy makes it to be able to play r i
mean this this is like the you know the
fan Zone and you're like the Afterparty
for the for the fan Zone James I think
people need to know right now pain the
stream is where you can find these guys
puzzling late night before the actual
competition so Andy Woodward let's take
a look at his profile right here James
because you said he was up late night
battling he's going to be showing up
today and guess what he posted his
personal best in 3-minute puzzle Rush
yesterday at 59 is he going to beat that
today oo 60 you know what it's a lot on
the line he got to you know face Hans
today like he's just I got to bring my
best game hopefully he got some sleep
cuz he was definitely up late playing
Puzzle Battle with Ray last night so
hopefully the kid got some sleep there
but if he's able he comes fresh today he
was a he the sky's a limit to say the
least right he broke his high yesterday
you know in the first round so it's
important to see you know what he does
the rest of year look at that puzzle
rating that's disgusting I mean mine's
like 3500 yeah I thought that was maybe
an error or something does that is that
a five that that is a that's a five in
the beginning there too as well not it's
not a three-digit number either oh my
goodness well that's Andy Woodward and
you mentioned he was going up against
Ray Robson late night let's talk about
Ray because I mean it's crazy to have
this competition and not talk about Ray
he's the four time puzzle world champion
of course a grandm and much older than
and Woodward but you know with ag comes
experience James can you just I mean can
we talk about this thre minute High yeah
you know what's funny like you know hey
hey Andy great job buddy you got 59 you
got your High I mean you're awesome
which he is but then at the same time
you're like well what did Ray do ray did
10 more than you did and then if you
think about that with Hikaru too as well
Hikaru with a high of 59 the only person
that's 10 more than Hikaru Nakamura you
know only person that has that is really
really Magnus in other formats obviously
winning world championships and these
championships more times than hearu but
look at that 10 that's a beefy 10 there
that's the highest ever I think it
really is 69 is absolutely incredible in
3 minutes so Ray Robson obviously a
front runner in this event but he's got
a lot of competition and all these guys
James they're going to be buying for
some pretty nice prizes as well let's
remind the people I mean there's a lot
at stake here you're not complaining KY
showing up solve a few tactics walk home
with some cash man look at that seven
place a th000 look I can show up halfway
through late you know what I mean tired
just waking up and then even lose all
your puzzle battles and I walk away with
$1,000 hey that's a good day that's a
great day 5,000 for first place these
guys have a lot on the line and I mean
we also have to remind people uh James
that the format for today is going to be
a little bit different from yesterday
right yesterday we had you know kind of
a Royale format everybody competing but
today we're diving into the koos and
most importantly it's an eight player
double elimination bracket so you're
watching you got a fan favorite here if
they lose guess what they're not out
just yet they go down into the losers
bracket you got the Winner's bracket
best of eight and the losers bracket is
a best of four and most importantly
James all the matches are played in
Puzzle Battle today I mean talk to us
what's the difference that we can expect
with puzz battle compared to yesterday
well first off Puzzle Battle I don't
know what they put in those puzzles here
we do have to take a talk with Danny as
we blame everything on Danny we know
this so always blame Danny but here I
mean the puzzle battle Parts it feels
like they're a little bit slightly
easier I guess I got 51 in a puzzle
battle with a three minute but then can
never even break 50 with a three 49
almost every time maybe can get a 51 day
it's hard it's easier I think Puzzle
Battle but also with that being said you
have to fight against your opponent it's
you and him it's not just you beating
your high score and three-minute puzzle
rush I think you have a little bit of
adrenaline there like you just want you
have that attack in you you want to beat
them but you can also strike out very
early too as well that's right you know
they always say sometimes you don't have
to outrun the bear you just have to
outrun the other guy that he's chasing
and I feel like that's kind of what we
got here in in Puzzle Battle and I think
most importantly to remind the people as
well these uh competitors will be doing
the exact same puzzles so you're not
going to be having like oh you got got a
lucky run or you got that puzzle I
didn't get that that one's easy NOP
they're going to be doing the exact same
one so James I really feel like this is
the ultimate test between two puzzlers
doing the exact same puzzles hey may may
the best man win May the best man win
and may the best Puzzler puzzle so it's
going to be fun to see of course we got
a nice lineup today this is important
puzzle battles are man it's so much
tension there too especially when you
see someone I know for people to play
Puzzle Battle you see that person like
you can see they're bored and they're
just like whipping through puzzles then
you get a little Society there and
you're just like oh I'm not going as
fast and then you blunder and then you
just lose so there could be a lot of
that today you know if you don't get
your nerves in check there you're you're
you're calling it I mean how does a
young player like Andy Woodward we see
him on cam right here how does he handle
that potential pressure anxiety of
seeing you know someone like Ray just
racking up the check marks across from
him he is up against in the first round
Hans Neeman James you you think he the
kids got it in him the kids definitely
got it in him today you can see he's
just ready he's locked in you got to
lock in as you see him locked in right
now is he playing who playing somebody's
playing right now it looks like christop
for you and and uh Ray right now yeah
this is a this is I I think this is
someone else there's are they going
right now I actually don't know that
looks like Chris that but uh maybe not I
think we might be watching a different
uh puzzle B yeah just working they just
want to work are they training did we
start you know what I mean like hey do
you know that it's about to start guys
or like okay cool they just don't care
they just gonna play it out wow yeah I
think yeah I'm wondering what so we got
is that Hans in the top right there that
it looks that looks like uh who is that
that is Hans top right okay Hans and
Andy they're fixing it blame Danny Danny
come on bro get get Danny out of here
get Danny man get him on the phone bro
but I think that I think that we have
started here by the way I just like to
point out no matter who we were watching
there I didn't see an X like the guys
were up at like 30 plus and they didn't
even know what Red X looks
like right exactly yeah this is I
actually hit my high remember being at
there at the chess brought path sitting
in that seat and I actually broke my
high for the first time in three minute
puzzle Rush which was I think it was 44
and 49 now so it's it's sentimental
there I remember senal so yeah you know
this this chair just like to say uh you
know if anyone looking to break their
High you know I'll be willing to sell
some chair space you know we'll auction
it off you know high sell some J space
that' be great yeah at chess bra pad of
course okay so these boys is this Ray
and Chris yeah it is it is yeah and and
this is the match that we were watching
so this was Ray and Christopher U and I
was talking about 30 with no X's but
what about this they're at 50 and they
haven't got one wrong yet All
Greens All Greens I'm a jinx yeah sorry
sorry to Christopher you commentator
curs honestly that was my
fault yeah yeah yeah yeah we can blame
Aman and Dan so 3 seconds left and
they're both pushing these 50s but two
x's James you know that feeling when
you're doing puzzles you get two wrong
all of a sudden you you just do them a
little slower CU you you know you got to
be careful don't want to be out yeah you
don't want to be out but also then you
have that person that's catching up or
they're above you right now for instance
as you see he's extending the lead plus
today's this best of eight so whoever
wins four and a half out of these
immediately they're going to start
another one whoever wins four and a half
it's a wrap it's over there so they're
all puzzle battling right now 51 52 man
he was close look at him going to
comeback look Chris dang that was very
close and we can see like we talked
about the high for Ray Robson that was
at 69 and he's here posting a 52 you
know obviously it takes some time to
warm up and you only need to be better
than your opponent so 52 was enough to
get it done in the first first game
there okay well I mean it actually feels
good cuz I hit 51 in Puzzle Battle but
that's it 51 and I was done you know
like you know you like hype but then
that's like that's it like Ray has
another gear a whole another gear is
different so what you're saying and by
the way James I'm in the same boat and
what we're saying is that our ties Ray
just beat with one of his runs to start
off yeah exactly he he reps it you know
what I mean he reps it he just does a
little does it for breakfast oh that's
cute you know he calls it cute oh 51
that's cute okay you know keep going to
work wow so I think when I'm when I'm
watching puzzles uh one thing that I
like to pay attention to um I don't know
if you do the same is kind of like the
splits it's like how fast do you get 30
how fast do you get 40 and right now the
guys are on a pace where they're getting
30 well before a minute has has gone by
yeah they said in fact I think yesterday
was
um Danny Danny said this he's here every
year doing uh the commentary portion and
he says uh having 40 with an a minute
and 30 is a very nice spot to be in so
that's like a a sweet spot sometimes if
you have more it's even better but if
you're at 40 with a minute and 30 you're
in the clear to have a very good run
potential right yep that makes sense and
you're talking about that pace the guys
are on it right now and you know when
they're 3737 like that neck and neck
it's kind of a a feeling of you know
you're working on the exact same puzzle
at the exact same moment so it's like oh
okay who's gonna be faster and sometimes
the one like we I play so much of it now
it's like this this the Strategic part
of like if they get it wrong and you're
like oh which one did you get wrong let
me slow down exactly oh you probably
played this let me play this oh got it
right you know it's like crazy little
tricks like this can give you that
Advantage though that's a good point
yeah because it's always a flex to get
one correct that they got wrong you're
like oh oh you got it wrong well I got
it right
buddy wow neck and neck amazing like
Christopher U he lost that first one but
just by one point and they are on the
exact same Pace right now Christopher
you is definitely swinging today if Ray
Taps into that second gear that you know
he was able to break 69 in three minute
puzzle rushan is going to be a problem
but of course so far so good you know
for everyone keeping up with him also
Andy and with 59 there yesterday which
is ridiculous so we're going to see some
crazy runs here yep and uh remember
there was a a 52 and a 51 and Ray right
now 51 with none incorrect is crazy in
fact he's already
won he 52 and yeah there it is he's
trying to finish off the Run look at
that he right with the flex chill bro
you won bro you won bro he's already
Dead He's already he won bro chill man
what is he
doing he's going for uh going for
another 69 there wow Dam
55 Dam that's impressive well why don't
we why don't we uh jump to another match
here uh also a battle between some of
the the youngsters and a guy who was uh
competing James on on our Channel this
is Prav you know we were we were
streaming and he was competing on our
Channel you know you know I'm I'm a
little biased here but given that I'm in
the commentary seat I say we you know
take a look at bov's match against Liam
putam and see how he's doing there
definitely you know V PR I remember when
he was just buddy you know now they call
him by his first and last name you know
you know right buddy you know now it's
just they grow up so fast type thing I
remember seeing them playing you guys in
the long Marathon matches on the stream
and now he's uh he's running the stream
look at him I mean it's insane the level
up from the kid no it is and you know I
I thought I was uh completely powerful
uh here James but you know Productions
telling me hey you know what you don't
run this show that's our show you know
stick with Ray Shay baby correct and
he's up to nothing he's up to nothing
now James he could win 5 right we're
talking about best of eight I'm not
saying it's the most likely outcome but
you know it is possible to just go five
wins and then you don't even have to
play all all eight matches it's a best
of eight yeah that's true best of eight
which could be crazy especially if you
start down 20 and you like okay this guy
is a mean he's mean he's very he's not
giving me anything here you know you get
that third one then you start all right
well I'm out type exactly first round
but of course hey like we said hey I'm
out well you know what hey cut the
chess what's what's the the link to the
invoice thank you I appreciate that get
that thousand from
y'all
all right so uh actually an early
mistake from both players there I mean
sometimes those early mistakes way on
you and as I say that two wrong at only
38 here so much pressure now because
he's going to be really slowing down I
see 45 yeah and this is looking like a
clean threepiece coming up Ray in the
zone locked in seeing everything only
had a few wrongs so far high today of 55
chat says 57 from little Andy there in
fact we gonna be calling him Big Andy
after this one 57 from Andy
apparently it's a nasty run there at the
bottom wow 57
48 yeah this is I mean he's just it's
like a playground at this point he's up
more than 10 he's already got the win um
do you do you think that this is just
you know you don't want to cut things
off he's just warming up he's just
starting you may as well get the rep in
before you go to the next game yeah you
know what's funny I guess he's just he's
warming up he's just he's using
Christopher you as just the warm up you
know he's like all right I'm warming up
here I'm just gonna get the warm up in
it says two to one now did he win a game
did Chris no I don't think so that's
that's that's got to be a a clean three
for uh for Ray that's three Pie's coming
in three pie coming 57 come on ra hill
bro dang bro dang
bro7
he don't even care he just this is a
very scary man you want to stay far away
from him ran okay I'm just saying you
want to stay very far away from Big Ray
and have a nice day and you know what in
in this format this KO format um I I
think it's worth mentioning I've been
talking about a clean five but although
it's kind of rare it is possible James
for these puzzle battles to be a tie so
you can actually win the match with four
and a half points and you can get that
tie by obviously having the same score
but also having the same number of red
X's so if I have like the three X's you
have three x's and we both have 41 you
know it actually is a a a tie a draw oh
yeah I remember that I remember seeing
that which is pretty cool that there is
a draw it's very rare that that happens
like sometimes for me only times I'll
have the draw is like you'll be I'll
have two x's we both on 41 I'm not
moving because if I get it wrong I'm
it's out and they don't move either and
then you get that draw and it's like
that's cool so it's awesome to see that
it is possible to get draws here not
very very likely but definitely very
possible yep very possible 54 is there
okay got some stuff moving around see if
we can move around anywhere else to V
pra over the Liam and see if we can take
a look at that soon if we got that up
yeah I think at the moment at the moment
we're sticking with uh with this one
honestly we might not have to stick with
it very long much longer James which is
a you know so sorry to Christopher U but
remember Christopher U even if he gets
wiped by you know the the four time
champion in in the first round guess
what he's not out of the competition he
could come back with a a villain Arc you
know with a Vengeance from the losers
bracket H yeah oh forgot you know what
one thing you do have to forget and this
could be like what do they call it the
Swiss Gambit in the way where don't try
this sit home of course but you know you
lose the first game or the second game
just to get different pairing so you can
run up through the rest of
of the of the field and then like you
know you finish on the back end
basically you know at first but losing
the first round type thing so you could
see some Swiss Gambit here from Christa
for you in fact losing to Ray in the
first and then coming all the way back
through the losers bracket it's very
possible with a double elimination
format which I think is a pretty awesome
format and I think you got to have some
mental resilience like I tell you James
when I'm doing puzzles and I get one
wrong my immediate thought is like no
the the puzzle must be wrong I was yeah
yeah right now no bro this is crazy bck
did that yesterday yeah it's like no
puzzle must be wrong like oh that's the
answer Ah that's that's so silly like
that doesn't make sense so I I tell you
I have the worst mental for puzzles but
these guys you know you get one wrong
you just go to the next one um so I
think you got to have that short-term uh
memory 100% but you have to have the
short-term memory on it you know the
puzzle wrong type thing called Danny did
I look at it I'm like okay well I mean I
guess it makes sense but okay I mean
okay whatever and then I just get to the
next one because I was wrong so I was
like all right cool yeah you're right
all right all right you got it
whatever and it looks like it's going to
be a 40 and it will incorrect
there and he's he's still uh still
looking good here 4 nothing for Ray
Robson so at this point it's looking
like the the Ray Show at least in this
first round matchup he's up against
Christen for you and I mean what a tough
pairing you know you show up for the the
final day and it's like oh yeah great uh
here's Ray Robson for you here's Ray my
round one you talking about Ray wait let
me check the uh check the paper and then
like scratch the paper acting like it's
not there but it is there yeah want to
see if you can wipe it off no it's still
there buddy you got
R it' be very interesting to uh you know
after this first round wraps up to take
a look at that bracket cuz then we start
to see like what are the next round
pairings who's in the loser bracket who
can make a comeback so very excited to
see that in these these first rounds we
might actually see a lot of lopsided
results yeah I mean I'm seeing at the
bottom here too is a rotating we have
the rotating standings down there pav
with a 50 every round he averaging 50
what you do this round 50 what was that
50 uh what what what 50 like it doesn't
matter answer is
50 he's doing everything yeah that's a
very strong showing from pav
there
I think you start to get used to the
skill from these players but like don't
don't let that make you forget how
impressive it actually is like just
because these guys are cranking out 50s
50 plus every single time I mean that's
incredible it really impressive the the
level of puzzles that we're watching
here oh that's definitely awesome that
that that level is always inspiring to
see averaging 50 is nasty a 3 minute PR
buddy like what is he doing Andy doing
the same thing 50 57 54 or 56 like get
off me he says get off me oh my goodness
yeah you a rotating scores at the bottom
of the screen uh for those watching
those will be the scores from the other
matches as well and up against it here
is Christ for you not only does he have
those two x's he's six points behind and
it's it's effectively Match
Point yeah this is it here uhis for you
you know he's like all right cool you
know the good thing is really that
double elimination makes it much better
you just feel better you're like all
right cool at least I got another shot
at this you know I I had to face the big
dog Ray it is what it is I learn some
things I keep moving I go through the
losers bracket and see what I can do
through there and also maybe inspire you
too as well when you get that ale to do
better man all green 50s hey Ray you
gotta chill bro yeah you gotta chill bro
that's incredible he has with the three
X's from Christopher U he has officially
won uh not only this particular Puzzle
Battle but the entire match which means
that we'll move on to the next uh to the
next segment of the winners bracket and
of course Christopher youu will drop
down to the losers bracket so this is
going to be a 0 first round Clean Sweep
for the four time puzzle world champion
no he this is 55 this is very impr okay
is he gonna get this right too yeah I
don't know what the high is for like all
green but this has to be you know one of
the runs I mean he 56 greens no X's
unbeliev you know and and on camera he
doesn't look happy he's
disgusted with nothing wrong it's okay
it's okay it's fine but but
okay it's geez like if I got a 56 with
nothing wrong like I'd be clipping that
YouTube video of the year like send me
the clip right now Ryan I'll be I'll be
so hyp no
absolutely that is the level that Reay
plays at that's the thing is that 56
with nothing wrong is is impressive for
him but not unheard of and that type of
score James I think is going to be
taking out a lot of people in this
competition but we have other matches to
take a look at and how about Jeffrey
your boy Jeffrey
John yeah he's against RX sadani and
this cooking up today in this KO so
that's also one that we want to take a
look at um but I mean I think we're
jumping into some matches here that are
hopefully G be a little bit more
competitive than that 5 at least in the
first round yeah yeah of course I mean
Ray does this to everyone in fact so
it's a common theme that we see so
hopefully uh there will be some some
some competition really for Ry here I
mean yes of course these guys are
competition not to say they're not but
Ray does very easily he makes it look
very easy as it's not so hopefully
someone can give him some problems as we
we would like to see that maybe that's
right we we we're trying to like
discover who the person is who's going
to like Dethrone Ray obviously after
that first round it's like okay uh I
don't know if there's anyone available
but there are a lot of strong puzzlers
in this competition that we just haven't
taken a look at yet so don't worry we we
we got some other wor it's coming out
guys coming up yeah it's crazy you like
yo we gotta get somebody for Ray and
it's not Hikaru like it's just yeah no
Hikaru got knocked out but like it's
different it's just different got Andy
here Andy Chef Jeff and some others Hans
too as well let me see what the score is
looking like down there well take take a
look at the bottom of the screen uh
James and for everyone watching because
even though the the matches aren't right
in front of us we can see the scores
that they're posting we can see the the
competition between Andy Woodward Hans
nean for example uh three to one at the
moment Andy those are some big
scores out here I get demotivated when
I'm playing somebody who's better than
me in Puzzles it's like you put up your
best and they do one more than you and
it's like yeah okay I've been there bro
that hurts you're like come on just no
hope come
on live yeah cuz I stream it live too as
well so it's really like oh all you know
what guys I'm done today no more puzzles
like I'm just out of it and you have to
keep playing though you have to keep
playing it's four to one there from oov
oh four to one who Liam got one that's
nice Li got that one so he's not out yet
yeah and I feel like that that one it's
almost like a you know for the ego
whether or not you win that match it's
like okay I got you though I didn't get
yeah I caught you with one yeah I caught
you that's right yeah yeah so I'm
looking at those scores there obviously
we saw Ray uh take out Christopher U and
you look at the scores that Christopher
you posted it's like they weren't that
bad like I I think sometimes in Puzzles
even though you see someone score and
it's like 35 when they're usually
posting 50s you can understand that what
happened was they probably got one wrong
tried to speed up to make up for it got
another one and say okay this run is
like trash anyway so it's going to be a
quick three and out all right yeah you
have to be fast you have to be quick
guys I mean try it at home you know in
fact let's get chat involved yesterday
we did the same thing what is your
puzzle Rush high in three minute what is
your puzzle Rush high in three minute oh
we got scores here as you put that in
the chat we have uh board stuff on
screen we have boards on screen so well
the problem is James some people are
putting their puzzle Rush high scores in
the chat and Jeffrey Jeong and ronx Sani
have already beaten
it they've already done
it it's it's tough out there guys are
like really excited oh yeah like 31
that's my high it's like great yeah here
it is on the screen here it is on the
screen guys here it is on the screen in
three minute with a minute and 50 left
on the
clock a li all right this is Jeff RX
adwani and we talked about some really
close matches in the first round this is
about as close as it gets you know what
they have already had what I said was
pretty unlikely but a draw in one of
their battles oh you're right yeah I'm
like looking like yeah three and a half
two and a half but yeah know this is
very it's it's not strange it's just
like it is okay strange but it's like
you don't if you don't get a draw you
don't know it's very very unlikely to
have like a draw here you get to like 40
or 41 even 49 whatever number with two
x's and you just kind of chill or or
even One X and you don't move and then
then the time runs out and you guys get
a draw which is very rare here so this
very
competitive absolutely two games there's
still the exact same score 3 and 1/2 to
2 and 1/2 for Jeffrey and remember it's
first to four and a half points that's
how you win that best whoa wrong and
wrong again this could be it for Chef J
that's it Jeff with the
bag dang and he he gets to that four and
a half and we were here for the moment
where jeffre Jeong is I mean he's still
puzzling but he's already got the win
Chef Jeff cooking up I like that I like
that name Chef Jeff oh yeah yeah we've
we've called him this for a while now
Chef Jeff is familiar Embraces his
cooking ability on the
board and look at him the guy he's he's
still going you know I will say
sometimes you just kind of tune out a
little bit your opponent's score you're
only like laser focused on the puzzles
so I can understand that these guys to a
certain degree might not even be aware
that they've won sometimes like you look
up and you're like whoa okay I've been
winning for the last minute right
exactly yeah I've done that before you
so locked in yeah and you're like oh
shoot he didn't me how long I've been
gone right thing 54 very nice very nice
look at Andy and Hans yeah we got a huge
matchup here Hans nean Andy Woodward the
uh
All-American that kid going crazy so
close right now
5150 they're doing the
puzzles oh yeah it's over it's over
Annie just locked in seconds Andy is
locked
in D 54 he out of there
all it is a half yeah I mean at this
point it's like the maybe if there were
draw offers and Puzzle Battle you're
throwing in right
now right hey uh draw interested in a
draw now what are those uh what are
those scores uh Wai didn't to see the uh
the scores roll around at the bottom for
this matchup cuz I'm curious what what
have been the high scores posted by
these two remember Andy Woodward posted
that 59 yesterday yeah he did at 59
which was beefy I mean that was a
personal best from him he just hit that
boy 59 that's very strong from the kid
there he does this every day as I was
talking in chat yesterday about this is
this is something that the kids do a lot
and Puzzle Battle puzzle Rush uh I have
you know my good look at those Andy
Woodward scores oh yeah he's he's a
beast for real everything 50 averaging
50 plus like somebody in the chest God
not7 54 4 56 54 yeah unbelievable that's
Ray numbers truly that's you know he's
he's looking like the biggest
competition for Ray at the moment yeah
that's Ray numbers he warming up with
50s you start warming up with 50s it's a
different League it's a different League
everything
50 pava is doing that too so uh in fact
pava is already I think he's right under
average wise 50 he's I mean he's at 50
but he's like a lower 50 than than Andy
right still 50 still 50 like these guys
GNA be Prav Andy and Ray are looking
like the strongest right now because you
know what um we always talk about how in
Puzzle Battle you just have to beat uh
the guy you're up against so let's say
that you know Andy posts a 59 and you
you post like a 35 like yeah he wins
that Puzzle Battle but then on the next
one if he posts like a 52 you get a 53
it's one to one it doesn't matter that
he won the first one by like 20 you know
or a bigger margin just about those
individual Puzzle Battle wins that's is
correct those individual wins right and
just staying locked in I think one thing
which they don't have when you know what
since we're talking to production here
in engineering and Danny get it fixed we
need it now we want actually to have the
focus mode option that you used to have
you know in Chom play mode you can like
Focus only on the board and not see
nothing else Focus board would be nice
Focus mode I mean would be probably nice
for puzzles too as well so you can be
able to only see your puzzles here
sometimes you're just focusing what they
say like when you're running a race type
thing and you look behind you and then
the guy passes you because he was
looking behind you right so important
and Prav I see just got that win five
to2 and man some really close battles at
the end just a single point or even the
X's determining the the final results
there Andy Woodward in this one he's got
52 but three X's this is the chance
here three X's he's he got it oh 52 he
got it I just claim to win and be out of
there but they just always continue he's
got it wow finish man that feels good
right shoot man now I would feel a
little bit better now I would feel a
little bit better from Hans here at
least just slightly right I'm still in
it I'm not out I'm not out did Prav win
his match he did five to two at the
final so uh this is our last match from
round one that's still ongoing and it's
heating up here huh nean is not ready to
go out just yet he's he's Clinging On at
4 to2 but Prav won his match we saw Ray
win his match and we saw Jeffrey Jong
win his match as
well okay all right yeah and where we at
four to two yeah Andy only needs a dub
here only a dub even a draw to do but
Hans might be locked in here so far so
good I ne and you speak about that draw
as if like oh might probably not going
to happen but in that last battle it
could have been a draw if Hans had got
that last one wrong with the the three
X's it would have been a tie and you
would have lost the uh the entire match
it's very very likely very likely that
it won't be a draw you're like what very
likely it won't be a draw oh that was
nice that was from your little um what's
that England Gambit line you be I got a
lot of fans and some people yeah I saw
this I saw am man play it the England
game at Queen sacrifice thing yeah do
that too much
guilty you are you're doing it you're
doing it a
lot let's see Hans you know if if the
people want more puzzles I got to be
cheering for Hans right now because he's
the one behind and if Andy wins it's all
wrapped up for this match and we will be
looking ahead in the
bracket okay check check check check
check mates oh he down 3643 you look
away for a second there I think I think
I blinked what did you gain 10 puzzles
gez yeah I mean that boy so quick he
sees it so
fast Hans is making a little bit of a
comeback here yeah the the speed is
kicking
in 47 here is what queen F2 looks good
there hits
mat yeah and at the same time great call
at the same time you know on the other
side we're here like working on one it's
like oh yeah three have already been
completed over there you're like oh
sorry dang wait oh I'm thinking too long
okay just make a move wrong oh wait I
got two left too many emotions you're
done out that's how fastest happens
thought process and all now we talked
about that pressure at the beginning of
the show Andy Woodward the Young Gun
he's at 51 he's got the lead but this is
where you got to put this match away he
has to do it now he can definitely do it
he has one wrong and he's been
consistently hitting these numbers today
oh yeah he got that okay 53 good job
yeah this is looking bad for HS 30
seconds yeah there's one
wrong will we be seeing a
repeat breath 54 he got it yeah 54 is is
huge that's probably going to secure
things oh it's a rep he's out of
there and the sigh of relief there from
Andy Woodward on cam his heads in his
hands he knows that was a close matchup
but he gets it done in round number one
he takes out Hans Neeman but of course
double elimination so Hans will be down
in the losers bracket Andy Woodward
making it happen that's nice and Hans
nean goes to losers bracket congrat so
impressive way he handled the pressure
there at the end you thought like maybe
he was going to choke it out like he did
in the previous uh previous battle but
calm cool collected seeing that maturity
from such a young uh young competitor
absolutely very very strong as he got it
done the kid got it done man but we saw
him do this yesterday you know he's the
number one seed did you know that did
you think like think think about this
for a second he is the number one seed
right now overr in fact that's right I
mean now that we have all the matches
wrapped up from that very first round
let's take another look at the bracket
and we see the updated information James
Andy Woodward we just saw him take out
Hans Neiman so he moves forward Jeffrey
Jong probably with be closest match up
against against Ron sadani neck and neck
they had a tie in there as well he moves
on and will face Andy Woodward and down
at the bottom there James we got Ray
Robson and Buddy
Prav that's going to be scary okay it's
going to be scary for Prav Prav is going
to have to up it but he been doing
consistent 50s that's been good for him
though and he w we going through and
then we got that losers bracket just in
case you forgot they're not out yet
someone is going to make it through and
challenge the winner at the end yeah I
mean make sure to pay attention to those
names just cuz they're down in the
losers bracket someone is going to be
coming with a Vengeance which means when
they get all the way to the end of that
losers bracket they're going to come up
you know back from the dead up to the
Winner's bracket and they're going to
see what they can do but remember one
thing in the finals the the guy in the
Winner's bracket does have two lives
still available that's what double
elimination is all about so even if the
losers bracket beats the winner bracket
in the finals they go again it's very
important to understand that losers
bracket is very it's cool I've seen I
think Hikaru the only time I've seen
that double Elm was Hikaru coming back
all the way through and winning y the
whole thing so it is very possible to do
um so that's what makes you know double
mm cool but also it makes it kind of
annoying for the winner all the way
through like I won all my matches and I
still lost like you know exactly exactly
but hey I personally agree with you
James I think it's the best format
double elimination it just sucks to show
up for the finals and then you're
eliminated you know not 20 minutes in so
uh I love the storyline aspect here but
we are going to take a break right now
James we're getting set for the next
round we got the winners uh bracket
matchups the losers bracket as well so
stay tuned guys here at the puzzle World
Championship James and I we'll be right
[Music]
back welcome to how to reassess your
chess the Fantastic book that was
written by the late Jeremy Suman
recently passed away but he has left a
legacy of the concept of the imbalances
that he elucidates so very well this
concept is really a GameChanger once you
hear it you can't really ever get it out
of your head a 1500 player didn't like
to just attack attack attack but Silman
beat it into his head listen you've got
to attack when the king is stuck in the
middle of the board looks like he might
be able to take it back but he said no
can do black decided to play Bishop to
C3 dropping a queen sack on the board
what kind of move is that we see a mate
threat that cannot be stopped and of
course if you take the queen Rook takes
and mate on a stick this is how Jeremy
Suman students play man that's a kind of
teacher you want to
have
the variant Community series continues
on January 4th with crazy house where
you can add your opponent captured
pieces to your own Arsenal six weekly
Arena tournaments held every Thursday
will be followed by a championship event
with cash prizes including a $11,000
first place prize the third and final
weekly Arenas will be streamer Arenas
featuring gifted Subs as prizes win any
of these events to qualify for the
championship and show the world what
you've
got join the variant club today to learn
more about upcoming events how to
participate and much much more see you
in the arena on chess.com
[Music]
a
d
[Music]
I like
birds
[Music]
he
say
[Music]
w
yeah
[Music]
welcome back to the puzzle World
Championship I'm Grand masteron H I'm
joined of course by James KY how you
feeling buddy yeah we feeling good man
there the games are crazy the puzzle
battles are uh amazing as well I mean we
see the 50 plus each time from some of
these young dogs here you got Prav and
Andy going off with 50s really
challenging Ray to like hey bro you
better bring your best because we right
behind you and all 50s is something that
you know even some of the best puzzles
llers don't manage because you know what
they just get an early one wrong uh have
a bad run it goes like Oh 41 like
they're capable of high 50s but they can
have those those low scores but to just
be a consistent 50 plus I feel like
that's Championship material right there
that's 100% Championship material I mean
we see Ray did that Ray didn't touch a
60 Ray 50 every time too high 50s right
which is insane that they're keeping up
with that so you know Ray is definitely
going to have you know his hands full
with these guys he is still the favorite
here but the kids Andy and pav are on
his tail for sure that's right and you
talk about Andy Woodward he's up against
Jeffrey Jong in the first matchup here
James we're going to get right into
things this is a another All-American
matchup so Andy Woodward is just you
know you had Hans Hans nean now Jeffrey
Jong he's got uh tough tough road ahead
of him absolutely he has to face Jeffrey
um and then all you still have the
losers bracket too like got don't forget
about that there's always people down in
the loser bracket that you have some
match ups down there to see who does
what how how they get through it's
important that double elimination makes
things very spicy because on the other
end there definitely can be uh somebody
waiting for you like hey you remember me
that's right and hey I mean look at that
I mean how what if I'm not mistaken
isn't that X the fourth puzzle oh snap
he that might have been a mouth slip or
something that does happen or like
yeah that can Happ or you just think
it's like one really basic Checkmate but
it's another basic Checkmate idea I've
done that too but it's throwing him
right now two r two two piece before 30
what
happened it is bad run for his standards
for sure 100% 100% it does happen we're
like you know bad things just happen
obviously through do through one mou
slipp andly to another then you really
actually get one wrong now you're down
to your last leg here
and you have to really focus which he's
good at doing and as you see right now
he's focusing but he does not have that
chance or that love for his uh for his
King here he needs to be careful almost
the way that I think of it is I think of
like Alexander Guk everyone says he's so
good in time pressure and it's like
great but but he doesn't want to be in
time pressure you know it's like
Woodward he's he's a great puzzle solver
like he can manage this comeback but he
doesn't want to be here I don't want to
be right with twox and he's look at him
keeping up getting it done Jeffrey All
Greens 43 making it happen Chef Jeff and
Andy Woodward
44 so impressive these guys are pretty
much at the exact same puzzle right now
but those two x's are going to play a
role he's just going to have to be that
much more cautious and look at Chef Jeff
beefing it up beefing up the score okay
cool yeah yeah get a get another one get
another one go ahead your move buddy got
to figure it out 30
seconds yeah super
impressive 46 he got to figure it out
he's doing it 47 but he got
that 4 oh my goodness aming so close
here Andy with two wrongs since 30
49 50 you better move you better move
Chef je he's out of there he's out of
there this one yeah he's got it and that
is a win punished for the early mistake
there and coming back to bite him
James but yeah I mean to to have that
run he got 20 right like maybe 19 in a
row from from 30 31 something like that
and then got one
wrong and I can tell you uh James we're
we're in for a very exciting match when
you have the the guy who's maybe the
perceived favorite losing in the first
round you know it's going to get spicy
yeah especially because you get a little
bit heated you
like even though you just lost to with
an excellent player he may I mean Chef
Jeff has made it to the semis and I
think sometime maybe not the final but
semis like every year you see him
getting through through through the
stages so to see that mean Chef Jeff is
a strong player Andy just being a
favorite here says a lot about Andy's
strength quickness and how strong the
kid is Knight of six is there yeah it's
nice yeah and he's he's right I mean the
thing is these early tactics these early
puzzles they fly by so quickly and we
hardly even have a moment to be like oh
this is a really important T this is an
impressive tactic it's like the position
barely even shows and and it's it's
already done they said Ray lost I'm
watching chat slightly I SC I look over
and they say Ray lost let me we gon
check the standings when they get that
thing rotating at the bottom my ears
don't deceive me uh James and uh I swear
I could have heard
Eric Hansen in the house LED out an
erupting cheer so that that does check
out that does checks out that checks out
Hansen at the house wow Big Chief over
there going crazy for pav look Rook o
o pav and Jeffrey Jang both taking
victories in the very first game of this
uh of this next round against obviously
the but what could be basically the two
favorites Ray and Andy so this will be
very exciting man that's is I mean hey
anything's up for grabs apparently buddy
say yeah yeah Ray what Ray oh I got a
ray gun for Ray what is this okay what
do you think this is wow Prav with a dub
over Ray that is a big day I'm feeling
amped if I'm if I'm a buddy Prav at this
point feels good and what a bounceback
from Andy you know talk about that first
round hey there's my Jinx coming in with
a with a red X for him but he's still up
by three four and
Counting and 53 yikes I mean I think I
kind of knew it was going to be scary
when after the first run like it was
narrowly close to the point that you
know Andy could have won with two x's
against
Jeffrey and although they both struck
out 55 obviously taking the win there
and bouncing back so it is one to one
you know this is uh also a reminder
James before we uh get back into this
Andy and Jeffrey Jong match the losers
bracket is happening right now as well
so want to bounce over to some of those
games too uh these are happening
concurrently so want to make sure that
we're showing some love to those players
because we'll we'll see them again Liam
putam Christoper youu we haven't yet
seen Liam in action but I'm telling you
James this guy young player as well
young competitor he posts some big 50s I
think he was posting like 57 58 59
yesterday as well yeah he somebody said
59 was yesterday the uh all green 59 he
posted yesterday he was just locked in
different type of locked in 59 that is
yeah that's pretty nasty they say Ray
just posted a 60 oh he was mad oh my
goodness Ray Ray woke up excuse me you
beat me right bet okay okay Dam yeah
keep in mind below the screen is this
going to be a victory for Christopher
youu I think so based on the X's right
oh yeah that's gonna be a victory that's
GNA be Victory 54 yeah based off the xes
and if I'm not mistaken look at the
first uh game christop for you Liam
putam right at the bottom of your screen
5353 5454 and it's going to be two
nothing for Christopher U both of them
were the exact same thing they had the
same score but Christopher U had one l x
Incredibly Close Incredibly Close that's
very nice Liam very very nice from him
in fact that 60 that Ray dropped Chad is
saying pav dropped a
57 you gotta score more than 57 to beat
Ray it's gonna be a bad day you know
what I
mean fun
match oh my good imagine that drop a 57
and it's like okay congrats not good
enough try again wow the match that
we're watching right now here in the
losers bracket I mean this is actually
one of the closest I've seen it
identical scores in both rounds so far
and yet it's two
nothing yeah yeah that's tough that's
tough but okay you know at least from
Liam here are feeling a little bit okay
you know what look we're it's very close
and Liam actually running up some
numbers here now he's up five in this
one now of course he can definitely
catch up him me and Chris but they got
the lead I feel good that's right yeah
know he he can definitely come back here
he's obviously posted the exact same
scores so it's not the situation where
it's two nothing and you feel like oh
he's been better than me every time it's
like no he's been just a a sliver better
so definitely something you can come
back from um James we got other matches
I want to bounce around also to Hans
Neeman and RX sadani these guys are
going at it also of course in the losers
bracket but looking to make a comeback
and Hans demon up 20 but looking like
he's going to lose this oh shoot bro the
difference like a 10 piece that's a
that's a way to come back when you come
back 53 50 44 let's see if you can tie
it up right he's gonna make it 2-1 right
now and this next one is going to be G
to be
intense definitely going to be intense
this is he has to strike back here Rak
that is rans is gonna feel more
comfortable once you get that three to
one you feel comfortable not to say that
you let loose or you let your guard down
but you feel comfortable when you always
have a 3-1 no matter what format you're
playing so 31 feels good so you have to
bounce back now this is very very very
critical for R
agreed so let's see good start for both
very similar obviously keeping in mind
those uh those metrics you know the the
pace that you want to be on you were
mentioning KY something like what 40
with a minute 40 on the clock that's
right a minute 40 even better the more
time you have on well okay it's obvious
but definitely The Sweet Spot is like
minute 30 plus 40 on with h 40 already
and All Greens too like you know having
anything wrong can definitely help or
definitely mess you up that's
nice buddy tied it up man chat chat
keeping us ahead pav W 54 53 oh he came
to play he came to play that's insane
that's insane no that's we got we got to
go there next I mean it's it's just
sounded like the the most hype matchup
maybe a preview of what could eventually
be the fin finals as well cuz you got to
feel that if you're going toe-to-toe
with Ray taking games off Ray like that
that immediately makes you a front
runner for the competition oh
immediately immediately like wait who
who is this guy who is this guy that's
ho what the hell did you see that
yeah eight in a row
just yeah I saw that too like what
happened there that was strange like I
know these guys are talented but can
they really do that no actually it's um
i' I don't know what it is it's some
type of maybe not a glitch but I don't
know what it is it's happened to me too
as well when I'm playing actually and
then I was like yo my opponent I'm up
like six puzzles and then I'm up like
three or four I mean um like two two or
three something like that but because of
that thing like it'll just catch up like
they've done them sometimes it takes
some second while their guard is down
yeah exactly right it makes you think
that uh they moved it a lot faster and H
isad right now but uh you know these
last 45 seconds are crucial pressure on
a clean 51 for Hans nean it's one of his
best runs I think clean green 52 clean
green
52 51 got to move yeah this is very
critical for R it's not looking good 30
seconds he's still thinking has not
found it there it is do you feel do you
feel like when you get a clean score
let's say 55 perfect do you feel like oh
man like I kind of left something on the
table because I had the three X's to
give uh no in fact I feel there I feel
very sharp I'm actually more ready to
play than I am doing more puzzles when
you do a clean one like that you're like
yeah I'm seeing everything now you need
to go play before you start fatiguing
like that's exactly you know how it
feels there but two seconds 55 a piece
oh oh he gets it that's a dub that's a
dub r with the dub ski get off me come
on
and that just made me that just made me
think you know how interesting it is at
the end maybe you shouldn't like just
try and try and try before the end
because then all of a sudden you have
more xes than
them yeah yep Dam this is why you have
to chill you have to wait you got
wait wow r that was clutch that was very
clutch that was very clutch it's tied up
well I mean after this super exciting
there's only one place that we can go
right now and it's Ray against pav we
have to see this next one we saw Ray
just get that win there I think it's
noted up two to two but Prav has the
four-time champion on the ropes here you
know I mean and I think you know I've
never
seen um Ray you know he just at the end
there if we when we first got here to
this scene here Ray put his hair back a
little bit you know over his head and
then let out a little breath to let let
you know like it was close or like glad
to get the dub I've never seen this type
of pressure on Ray in this format so
Prav is bringing it to him right now he
absolutely is and and let's remember uh
something that's quite important which
is that the matches in the losers
bracket are much different than the
winners bracket it's best of eight
versus best of four so here we have a
best of eight we got lots of puzzles
ahead yeah in fact they are asking too
chat as well is is he using touch is
that touch or like or is it his hand
maybe he's left-handed and using his
left hand and his right hand's on the
screen that's possible because that
doesn't look like his finger his thumb
is moving too fast like gu that's I
don't think he's doing that what do you
think there yeah so I actually I
actually know the answer because he was
playing on our stream and he prefers
touch like he he thinks way way faster
on touch and I have heard this from a
lot of other more Elite puzzle
solvers that is the strangest thing I've
ever heard of my life in fact yeah and
I'm over here like no that's not
possible exactly I'm the same way like
it's just not possible bro I don't
understand how you're doing this like we
have to get that on film you got that's
we need that Aman we need that somehow
good thing about this competition is we
are getting it on film so here we go we
need a different angle we need to see
how this is working I mean let's talk
about Ray right now two wrong before 40
this is not his run he's feeling a
little bit of the pressure here as Pav's
up six and has all his exes well buddy
it's not going to be a good day buddy CA
it's Buddy goodness 47 he working Ray
right now running up the numbers working
Ray but it's still even there is still
another match it's going to be three to2
um expecting Ray to lose this one as it
as it looks it's not over but we do
expect Ray to actually lose this one
yeah this this is not looking good for
uh Ray Robson at the moment but you know
he's the type of guy that can definitely
do these tough ones just as quick as the
easy ones and and pav stuck here trying
to figure it out he's stuck and if Ry
the good thing about Ray Ray actually
when it when he gets into the deeper
puzzles y he does very very well here
but okay he got past it he got past W
that's a good point he was stuck there
but he used the time ended up getting it
correct totally worth it there we go
10 seconds left is it even possible to
do you know six puzzles in 10 seconds
there's no way not mathematically R
mathematically possible look at Ray oh
my goodness Ray is like are you kidding
me bro don't make me put my arm through
this camera right now he is not happy
incredible this Infamous water this is a
lead for Prav we're going to jump over
to Jeffrey zong Andy Woodward light
speed there's lots of matches Happening
Here
this is also in the winners bracket best
of eight
here okay Chef Jeff cooking up some
spicy look at him work Chef Jeff was not
expecting this like honestly I mean I
think Andy is just a heavy favor here
and also he has momentum behind him too
Chef jet was uh not on the the radar as
uh top three in fact
mhm yeah he's up 3-2 right now Andy
Woodward two wrong at the moment and
yeah I'm just feeling like you know is
is the pressure setting in a little bit
is Jeffrey Jong just that guy Jeffrey
Chef Jeff we cooking up something spicy
I got what you need I'll cook it right
here Chef Jeff three to two he's doing
well this was not expected to be honest
more favorites were with uh with Andy
now Andy heating up here Andy heating up
but Jeffrey is up three to2 yep
4242 and one thing I've seen from Andy
Woodward one thing I've seen from Andy
Woodward is when he's got those two x's
it doesn't stop him he still posts like
a high 50 just go on a streak it's crazy
yeah it is kind of crazy I have seen
that where he's you know the two doesn't
really bother him I've also seen that
too from Andy to as well these Elite
puzzle solvers as you said before you
see that all the time and here we go oh
bad spot for pavf bad spot for him but
as you say that you know commentator
curse an X there for Ray kind of early
on but nav is going to have to do what
we're just talking about with Andy going
a massive streak of probably like 20
puzzles here if he wants to keep up
yeah's he's gonna have to do that in
fact but me okay 39 37 yeah that was a
fast one lots of moves there getting
them all 41 trying to run away with it
says
Ray yeah he knows he's in a tough in a
good spot here rather for Ray he can
kind of sit here and just match his
opponent's Pace like if pav is sitting
there tanking on a puzzle he can take
his time as well very good observation
in fact that is nice uh strategy if he's
taking time on that puzzle cool you
thinking I'm thinking you moving I'm
moving exactly I move just like that
buddy just like that 42 45 yeah Ray is
cranking these puzzles right now all
correct 4743 but kav is giving him a run
for his money this is the most exciting
match we've seen and I've been saying it
I think this might be a preview of the
over all final 4844 though looking great
for Ray here
4844 nice job Ray yeah I think Ray's
gonna close this one out it's looking
good it's looking good for Ray which
will be 33 man and two games left really
because you need to you know four and a
half right wins the match 33 but I mean
incredible for Prav if you taking it to
Ray like this look at come yeah oh what
a what an attempt hold on three seconds
didn't quite manage he's got this
wow so close it's three to three after
that one uh James and remember it's not
even match point because it's a best of
eight so four is not enough four is not
even enough Ray with the chuckle there
little chuckle and he gets back to work
yeah that's a that's a competitor
chuckle like okay you know all right all
right okay Young fella okay yeah you
nice you nice let me get this work all
right let's go so I the interesting
thing for me is like Ray Robson expected
you know he is so good at puzzles he's
got the pedigree for naav I'm kind of
wondering like where did this name come
from has he been working on puzzles on
the side like I'm wondering how he's so
damn good at puzzles yeah it's that it's
that work behind the scenes a lot of
people only see what you're doing in the
light you know they don't never see they
never see what you're doing you know
behind closed doors here when no one
else is watching that work is the most
important work and for now is obviously
doing that type of work to be able to
keep up with Ray 100% three three right
now and of course uh at the bottom of
your screen always reminding uh the fans
to to take a look at that right there
because that'll be the scores from you
know around all the matches even though
we don't have them up on screen that'll
keep you guys up to
date an early mistake here for Buddy
Prav yeah definitely I'm maybe a slip
finger slip on his end
exactly exactly not any M he's not using
a mouse
here and uh in that Hans Neeman match
against rck interesting to note in the
losers bracket it was 2 to2 but R won
based on the tiebreak system
so yeah did go through he did go through
oh my goodness that hurts it does
dang
wow I mean what can you say perfect 40
41 now for Ray Robson not with that
early X but it hasn't seemed to phas him
so
far 41
39 42 39 43 he's doing good All
Greens he's on to something he's rooking
chat let him Rook let him
Rook 46
42 more correct for
he that's the thing is like you you
don't need to just beat this guy once
twice three times no you got you got to
keep getting he does not go down yeah
you gotta beat well in this case you
have to beat Ray four and a half
times four and a half times but I mean
hey Pav's like well I did it three times
I'm one and a half more than anyone else
would be right
now so 50 with 20 seconds
left Jeffrey Jean has won his match and
he will advance uh further in the
Winner's bracket Prav three x's and that
means that now officially it's going to
be match point because Ray is taking
this one and will be up four to three
and that is it yeah wow Ray with four
getting the job done there Hans in chat
by the way as well congrats on making it
as far as you did good puzzles big
dog yeah un fortunately you know going
out on tiebreak is one of the toughest
ways to go cuz you're like oh man like I
was right there right there truly yeah
yeah he definitely was definely was
feels bad man but hey double elimination
Lisa had his two shots I do like that
format a lot so um we're tuned in now to
Ray against Prav and this is a super
important match can Prav Force some
tiebreaks
here right you want you want it to be
tiebreaks uh that's your best shot you
know see see what the tie Brees can do
for
you okay let me move this away actually
computer is
like that's okay you know you're just
reminding the people that we're at a
racetrack here and they
got
you definitely have to move some stuff
around I got a lot of tabs and stuff
open as I uh fix this okay on a very
similar Pace 26 a piece remember that
you know that hitting 30 before a minute
is up Mark I think they're both
basically doing that there we go right
now and James you mentioned before the
next 30 seconds elapse hitting 40 is a
fantastic Pace to be on yes that's a
fantastic Pace or 100 a minute and 50
here is very nice but you want to be
like minute 30 um with 40 plus so he's
going like minute it looks like minute
40 with 40 almost 38 39
yeah he's right on he's right on minute
30 incredible he's right
on this is all green though from pavf to
as well shout out to him
4242 talk about keeping Pace a draw sh
you want to draw bro I think actually he
doesn't want to draw exactly not he
really doesn't not want to draw this is
unbelievable I mean Ray Robson is just
the like the king of this entire
competition and he's out here facing pav
who's shown him that he's got almost an
equal this is very good very good from
pav 5049 All Greens All Greens steel
steel all green
wow I'm just not that you want them to
get one wrong like yo are you going to
give one wrong oh there it is okay and
that one it was very interesting I think
Ray actually saw the puzzle first but
then took uh his time on it got it right
exactly where pav got it wrong wow hey
55 green he we saw him do this already
what was his high today green I don't
remember I think it was 55 right here he
can touch 60 what is this oh he did 60
already though he touch 60 once today OV
got that one right where Ray got it
wrong 20 seconds left
57 heat
58 so much on the line here goes for the
check I guess it maybe it was night D6
or Knight
d8
but 61 don't do it to him don't do it
don't do 61 to him oh man he trying oh
he couldn't get it off and he's mad he's
like I couldn't yeah he is mad he iset
what like ah no 61 for me I think a
double 60 bomb in that uh competition
with Prav there what a match that we
just witnessed Ray ultimately moves on
but James would you would you say that
at the moment Prav might be the guy to
watch in the losers bracket pav is the
other Ray the smaller Ray the Little Ray
you got Ray then you got little Ray and
that is uh 100% Prav right now as Prav
is a force to be reckoned with you do
want to fear him as much as you fear Ray
absolutely that that was really really
exciting let's take a look at our
bracket and see how things shape up
after those results we do see up top in
the Winner's bracket of course moving on
Jeffrey J over Andy Woodward maybe a
little bit of a surprise there but the
youngster still has a lot to prove he'll
be coming out of the losers bracket
Jeffrey Jong against Ray Robson in the
Winner's bracket is our next matchup and
James looking down in the losers bracket
there what are the uh the names that
you're looking to maybe reappear up top
again yeah you know what definitely Prav
there and Andy Prav and Andy Woodward
are the ones that you're like you know
what yeah that'll be a heavyweight match
up of course they were like the top like
Ray Prav and Andy that you've seen they
were averaging you know 50 so we'd love
to see those guys duke it out for sure
uhhuh absolutely I I agree we're going
to be seeing a lot of those names again
but want to remind people about puzzle
week James we want to ask the people you
know are you a puzzle expert because
this puzzle week we are looking for the
strongest puzzlers in our community and
we want to give you guys some prizes as
well so you guys can submit your best
puzzle rush and survival scores the
green pawns Twitter for the chance to
win Diamond membership and you know kind
of a cute little uh mittens plushy right
there use exclamation mark Puzzler in
the chat for more info on that and James
we have some really really exciting
matchups coming at you next there's
still some big puzzlers like you said in
the losers bracket Christopher youu of
course Andy Woodward just some big names
and we will bring you those matchups
right after the break let's
[Music]
go hello V come V come so this is where
the magic happened happens and this is
where all the magic has already happened
yes that's a good way of putting it
that's my world
junior 87 it's difficult to tell you how
many doors that open for me and what
what historical moment it was and when I
got back the chess
Oscars very nice these five of them W
five and there's one on top that is the
sixth one so since he had already got
five they didn't want to give him the
same trophy so they gave him a trophy of
a king with the world in his hand this
is anand's first ever mention in a
newspaper oh so this is his first ever
he was mentioned V Anand achieved a
national record by winning all the nine
rounds to notch a maximum of nine points
in the sub junior Championship imagine
now TS ri's daughter Rak is part of the
West chess Academy I mean it's so
beautiful to see how you know life comes
around so World rapid chess and mind
Champion so this was nit gave me this
nice why do I get the feeling that ARA
knows all the trophies and why one
better than you remember it cuz I
cleaned the because it's true because
it's
true you have a favorite thank you so
much an I feel this is extra motivation
for all the youngsters this opportunity
to actually come here and witness these
achievements and spend time with you in
this stunning room Anand Aruna thank you
so much for
[Music]
this can you beat Magnus
Carlson okay yeah probably not but what
if we give him a few
distractions can you beat Magnus while
he's
cooking what if he's playing
football how about Magnus
skiing surely you can beat him
sleeping now there's a Magnus for
everyone this month on chess.com
[Music]
you
e
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
I like
birds
[Music]
w
for
[Music]
sh
oh
[Music]
welcome back to the puzzles World
Championship we have some exciting news
for you guys Hans Neeman has been
reinstated in the event and I'll do my
best to to explain what happened I think
it's actually pretty cut and dry there
was simply a glitch and his score that
he scored on his stream did not show up
properly it didn't register properly so
the tie break which comes down till your
your the score is added up actually that
updated score means he does beat ronx
sadani on tie breaks he will be back in
the event and he's going to be up
against buddy Prav in the losers bracket
so James I mean we had Hans in chat and
I was like man you know sucks to lose on
tie breaks and he was probably thinking
what the heck I'm pretty sure I won on
tie bre I won on tie breaks you're like
wait huh and then everything and then
it's crazy and it comes out that
everything is just fine boys and girls
it worked out and this is why you got to
have your own state it just got to you
just got to know you got you got to know
you got to be involved you know like the
even LeBron type stuff like you got to
just know what you're doing on the court
the whole time everything and it got
overturned look at that you know what I
mean it had to be Hans of course this is
a WWE script H Hans nean you know
overcoming adversity he's back in the
tournament but guess what before we get
there we're still in the winners bracket
this is the winners final best of eight
these guys haven't lost a match yet one
of them is going to right now Jeffrey
Jong and Ray robs
okay Jeffrey zong right Chef Jeff is in
for a long day at the office but I mean
hey he can go through the losers bracket
too as well just saying worst case
scenario but he can it is possible to
upset right hasn't happened yet but it
is possible just we don't know who's
gonna do it so it is he's up for it but
he's doing good good Pace all green yeah
I'm really really excited to see how
Jeffrey performs here because Jeffrey is
just I feel like flying under the radar
a little bit in this this event been
talking about a lot of other names but
then you're like wait a minute Jeffrey
Jong hasn't lost yet he's up against Ray
he's in fact on a better Pace than Ray
right now is this Ray or is it Jeffrey
you're like whoa in fact Jeffrey is
doing very well up two of one now green
finishing out the puzzle
45 good Pace this is impressive great
job Jeffrey great start I think he just
you know you have to know when to lock
in a little bit more and right now he's
doing that oh I had this puzzle on
stream that rookie 81 with Rick D on
this was a cool one and that's the
that's the pattern recognition even you
sitting here watching oh yeah I had this
puzzle uh 31 days ago at 7M
Eastern on stream fact yeah yeah yeah
this is fun man the 50s are the hard
ones man them boys I mean and the way
that he read us through them him meaning
uh Ray whoa that's too wrong Chef Jeff
yeah you talk about pressure now maybe a
little bit but the one thing about Ray
is I feel like he he might not have that
speed of some of the others like some of
the other guys can really show up early
but Ray just doesn't seem to get them
wrong that's what crazy yeah he only got
one here but that second one sheesh oh
51 if he keeps the score up 20 seconds
Ray got a move he finds
it he finds it oh he's out of there he
is out of there and you know Big Ray
have a nice day he's GNA find this 52 I
was going to say in that situation 5151
you've got 1 x if I'm not mistaken
shouldn't you just let the time run out
because then you get the win because you
have less mistakes whereas if you
attempt the puzzle what if you get it
wrong and then attempt the next get it
wrong you know what I mean yeah that's
right that's Ray just saying look I've
been doing this longer than you you know
what I mean like I'm gonna get this
right in regardless because I'm claiming
to win when it's there you claim it you
just claim the win and be done because
you have that option to claim win I'm
claiming that boy it did yeah I've never
clicked it faster so that's that's what
I'm saying this is a best of eight Ray
taking the early lead but you know what
James let's switch over to a matchup
that we didn't even think we would have
in this competition because H nean he's
the guy that wasn't supposed to be here
but guess what he's back he's against
pav right now in the losers bracket but
if you lose when you're in the losers
bracket guess what it really is a full
elimination so kav up one nothing Hans
back in this competition James wow and
already I mean it tells you how fast
this stuff goes we already know it goes
super duper fast but man one0 already
but I mean I kind of I seen this with
Prav when you're able to keep up with
Ray the way that he did put Ray on his
heels there go toe for toe you were up
at one point against the best ever Ray
Ray at this you know pavf is definitely
showing a a different side here he's
showing what's possible as Ray could
have went down in that match just as
much as uh pav did so you know he's
doing good I think Prav is a favorite
here but Hans is definitely back for
vengeance totally yeah they're on the
exact same Pace right now they had a
really close first round as well
5351 and yeah I mean it just literally
doesn't get more neck and neck than this
40 a
piece 40 up 40 down all greens and hey
on your pace that you mentioned it was
they both had 40 at a minute 40 oh very
ni yeah they're they're they're on on
Pace to do something very spectacular
but they got to move fast why not why
her holding a monitor like that you know
he's actually using a touchpad believe
it or not and I think he's using didn't
you say he's using both hands here
Aman yeah so I I think when you when
you're doing touch you generally use
like one hand but you almost use the
other one to like to like stabilize you
know keep the keep the tablet
steady yeah he's playing this is saying
to me like I just cannot interesting
fact about Prav um he's
left-handed oh he's doing that with the
left hand too with the left with the
left right with the left layup with the
left very nice left hand layups from him
in this match period just the showing is
nice I actually learn how to use the
mouse with both hands here I think is
good ergonomics to be able to do that
especially when you have long Marathon
matches using your dominant hand um
playing lots of Chess and Etc so AG you
know when the Chatters come in and say
hey I challenge you to beat me with your
left hand you stay stay ready Stay Ready
nothing except bullet bullet is not
can't do yet but one mistake for pav but
wow this could not be closer 54 perfect
run from Hans Neeman he is destroying
this right now 54 all green see like I'm
coming back oh that's two that's two and
Prav actually needs 56 remember he gets
55 he would lose based on the mistakes
T ah look at him pump look at him doing
some karate like this man what he doing
some karate now what is he doing he
going off like turn up ah this what I do
yeah let's go he really he really is
feeling it right now one to one and this
is a best of four so remember like it's
not like the Winner's bracket where you
can drop a a game here and there this is
very very intense because remember like
it's over at two and a half
points right oh yeah I forgot this is
best of four I keep forgetting that one
yeah yeah this one's even scarier oh you
gotta be fast bro it is best of four
yeah losers the losers man it goes very
quick um CRA let's let's leave now
before so we maybe can come back when it
gets intense but we want to check the
other match in the losers bracket it is
one to one Andy Woodward and Christen
for you one of these guys will be going
home after this match and look at those
scores Andy Woodward Christopher U 52 a
piece in their last one but Chris
getting the win based on the
mistakes 41 42 to 35 just what a lead
here he's really opening up uh I mean he
hasn't even got one wrong yet so this is
looking great he's got 45 at a minute
and a half here Andy
Andy this is one of his best runs I
think it it certainly could shape up to
be 50 before a minute is the pace that
he's on right now bro that's crazy 504
minute I wonder how big the board is too
like that these are things that are
important in fact how big the board
actually is matters because the draggon
and
Etc okay get I'm wrong it's
understandable queb two correct I me 52
at a minute is just insane pace what is
this bishop B5 Queen something yeah yeah
I know it's understandable that's a hard
one look at Christoph for you he's he's
just you know not maybe not as fast at
the moment but he's getting it done
perfect run so far 51 no mistakes
52 he's on the same figuring it out nice
C6 takes takes and this is the one that
Andy got wrong takes Bishop B5 it was
King C5 and I don't know what's next is
Queen E5 mate oh it's Queen E5 yeah
rookie five he did the same mistake yep
that's crazy that's crazy 56 from Andy I
was calling it early I think this was
going to be one of his better runs he
was on great Pace 56 killing
it 54
577 come on kid
58 hit him 58 oh my good 58 and he
great that's a f
from he's going to be
up1 but James remember I said we were
going to check this one out before we
jump back to Hans and Prav we got to go
uh we got to go to that one because I
think they're I feels like they're a
little bit ahead of these guys in their
match so we want to want to catch the
conclusion there of that one
and run not get this one yeah 2-1 and
now we got one more this is it he has to
win
what's the tie break for that what's the
uh oh is it just tie breaks again the
tie breaks thing no yeah that would be
funny if we had another Hans even TI
situation so let's see here very
possible it is possible
um I was wondering why the games were uh
not starting there I was like man did
did H score not get reported correct
again but I think we're good think we're
all good
here we're good match point for pav and
remember this is is not just you know uh
any old win this actually eliminates
Hans demon from the event so Hans got to
play for his life right
now wow
15 All
Greens that's
right yeah you can't afford a mistake at
this point we have worried that Ray is
up three 0 against Chef Jeff as well by
the way three 0 great up three 0 wow
I was reading the chat and someone was
saying that Ray lost with a 58 but now
I'm wondering whose information I can
trust can never trust the chat wow okay
yeah yeah chat is uh sometimes 500 ELO
or 55 H ELO there's never in in there's
no in between there's no in between it's
always one or the
other same exact Pace once again this is
a really really close
matchup
35 34 go go go go go Greens Greens
Greens all GRE oh dang got that wrong
yeah commentator curse I'm telling you
immediately like so crazy how that
works okay and Prav got the one uh
correct that Hans got wrong but despite
that mistake Hans is surging oh oh
commentator immediately like immediately
we got to stop we got to
stop oh it was immediate like oh man he
got it right boom and like okay M oh
this is a draw puzzle oh it's wh's move
oh so it's just this is deeski Page what
is this uh
321 that Flex in the memory there James
yeah you just pushed the pawn through
you just push the pawn easy and then
King up push the pawn push and push easy
321 nice here we go uh one wrong there
for Prav but he is a little bit ahead
right
now man the pressure must be on so much
right now because Hans nean can't get a
single puzzle wrong or he's eliminated
from the whole competition pressure at
its highest yeah but you know I'm glad
he can't hear you because that
immediately would hurt like you can't
get a puzzle wrong or you're out you're
like oh man and then what do you do you
get one wrong but he does it 47 oh neck
and
neck oh my
God 48 48 oh this is so intense he got
it
already 49 here it
is 50 50 50
back oh my God you can't
draw neither one of them wanted to
attempt it because if they got it they
would lose oh it's a standoff that is
two and a half wait a minute that's a
loss two and a half that's the match
that's the match oh my God that's the
match
yeah Hans nean is going to lose because
they're dead equal and they actually
Drew which means pav
advances best of four it is yikes yeah
very very very close match here W so
Hans actually had to go for
it yeah he had to but it was difficult
so difficult with just a second left oh
my God that's insane and it was this ing
game too like you got to push the pawn
and figure out move the bishop or like
wait what is going on right like what do
you actually want very difficult maybe
even promote to a knight or something
crazy
like I'm I'm messed up just even trying
to think of
it wow Prav congratulations very nice
work from him as he made it through
again once again we was talking about
the three Ray um pav and Andy he stays
in the competition we got to go to the
match in progress here oh my goodness
this is Ray and Jeffrey we're back to of
course that best of eight but with 40
man it's looking like Ray doing Ray
things yeah it's kind of scary bro just
like four oh hey man let come on bro can
you let somebody else win like hey man
look no honestly it's very impressive to
see Ray on this level here which shows
again how strong Prav is I mean it was
three to three Ray Robson run by four
and a half to three very respectable
score on Pav's end definitely a force to
be reckoned with here as Chef Jeff is
unable to put a dent anywhere in uh in
Ray's armor and one thing that I keep
noticing is that you know as good as Ry
is there are actually other competitors
that are faster than him initially but
Rey picks it up at the end like he turns
a a low 40 into a 60 just like that he's
just so consistent yeah what I've
learned from Ray over the years and
watching him and implementing myself you
watch the players that are great and
then you implement and what I saw him
from him is you know a lot of times you
see people go very very fast but then
they'll get them wrong later on so I
like to use what Ray does which he just
goes the same Pace the whole time he
uses a pace you can be faster than him
but when he's going to get them all
right or at certain levels he can go
high faster like when it gets harder he
can be faster because he knows it it C
better right I like the pace he does
well Jeffrey je his best opportunity to
get on the board right now and continue
this match
5148 Ray starting to as we were talking
about just build those he's just getting
them so quick it's already 51 already 50
look at that about to get this one too
push found it oh wait 52 though that was
clutch that was clutch come on Chef Jeff
Cook he
cooking five four oh 52 he got it 53
that's it he got it one second left is
Ray gonna get it oh he doesn't just not
in time wow what a win on the board
there yeah he got it that feels good you
know that's the like hey I didn't lose
by I didn't lose all of them that's what
you always say like you know I didn't
lose them all so he got a dub he got a
dub he has a huge comeback to make here
which is unlikely that you have to win
um three in a row here totally and and
look at those scores like between Ray
and Jeffrey if I'm looking at those
previous scores what about the one
before this 5453 he lost by one what
about
5353 he lost by the amount of mistakes
you take those results flip them the
other way totally different match so
even though it's four to one James I
feel like this is actually a closer
match than that represents yeah because
Jeff actually has some great runs there
as you see besides the other the other I
mean that's still probably averaging 50
with that 48 in there it's like average
50 which is really nice that average 50
is a difference different level there
it's just nasty I think my average is
like
45 46 because I hit 49 sometimes 50 but
that's it that's it where you at now am
I know you in the 50s right I actually I
uh I only hit 50 in 3 minute for the
first time on the day before the the new
year so that was my finished 2023 I hit
a 50 but a 50 ball know it's not my
thing it's not my thing yeah it's
definitely difficult bro hitting them 50
55s and 60s are
insane these guys are hitting 50 like
casually it's been 50 every single time
and we're talking about that's my
all-time high
lifetime life yeah same same right
exactly lifetime lifetime
High Queen H6 RI over nice very nice
again Ray Jeffrey come on Chef Jeff
working he's not as quick as some of the
other competitors Jeffrey can
consistently outpacing him but then
messing up later on yeah that's tough
you can't you can't you know you can't
allow
that here we
go yeah exactly you're right you get it
wrong I got you bro hold on that sucks
because you you know you're the guinea
pig
there what is this one I takes H3 oh
yeah and just run to
safety 94 there's rookie five no tilt by
uh Jeffrey though there it is rookie
yeah no tilt 48
Jeff Jeff he hot too WR but he's going
hot
49 it's going to be 49 a piece oh three
wrong wait so he shouldn't attempt this
he shouldn't attempt it claim I'm
telling you that's the way to win you
just sit there you just claim the win
bro you can click the button it's right
there claim win I know it's there it's
every every I've played I
know what a F50 at50 he still does
it and that's going to be enough he he
wins it decisively nice very nice very
nice that's it that's your winner of
that match right there Ray Robson he
just went the entire Winner's bracket
without a loss so he now sits in the
Winner's bracket and he just says okay
all right well you guys figure out who's
going to come play me yeah he about to
go get some some lunch all right guys
I'll be back just call me when youall
ready
I have no more work to do I'm waiting
for the finalist well big have a nice
day after a very eventful round there we
need to refresh update everybody on the
bracket this is where things stand at
the moment of course we just saw that
match between Ray and Jeffrey so as I
mentioned Ray in the winners final takes
the win so he's going to be uh waiting
in the Grand Final and now it's all
about down below James that losers
bracket we have the first match up Prav
against Andy and then the winner goes up
against Jeffrey Jean James what do you
make of this this one is going to be
crazy I'm excited to see that match up
with the kids Andy and peral they like
yeah I see you he like no I see you like
no I see you no I see you well we see
each other then and that's what this is
about because they are definitely on the
same wavelength that's going to be a
very heated match up there and then at
the end you got Ray so it's like Havey
day what excites me James is that now we
get to focus on these individual matches
we're not going to be jumping around
it's going to be Prav and Andy it's
going to be the winner against Jeffrey
and then it's time for the grand finals
so guys we'll be locked in to these
upcoming matches but RAV against Andy
Woodward in the puzzle World
Championship coming up right after the
[Music]
break still plenty of options and
opportun is left all right next one you
ready yes let's do it kasparian study
why to
move okay I know this you know it it's
not fair Queen A3 Rook Rook B2 Rook B2
very good kasparan kasparan study yes
looks kind of
familiar
but okay yeah Rook D2 Rook B2 Rook one
so how do you start Queen A3 Rook A2
Rook D2 D2 Rook takes A3 Rook D2 Rook A2
Rook one very nice very nice well done
okay so it's Queen A3 check A2 then Rook
D2 R A3 Rook B2 R A3 R B1 very nice very
nice
yes impressive knowledge another study I
mean if you know this one be mightly
impressed
why to move okay this one I don't
know so it's 10 seconds as well 10
seconds
oh yeah Bishop B6 C5 que B8 B6 King C8
King C8 King E4 H4 H4
um now I have to yes King F5 and H5 and
King E4 very nice is King E4 the final
move Bishop B6 Queen B6 C5 Queen B8 B6
King C8 King E4 yes H4 and King five H5
and King E4 King E4 back yeah very nice
well done okay this one is a bit
difficult say so I guess Bishop takes B6
yes Queen B6 C5 yes Queen B8 B6 mhm Ken
C8 mhm
C7 Queen B
s uh C7 might not be correct
oh oh King E4 King E4 yes yes yes H4
H4 you have a Pawn on G3 H4 and H6 right
yes okay
k54 exactly yeah very nice that's the
one very
nice
[Music]
back
e
[Music]
two
welcome back to the puzzle World
Championship you can see on your screen
right there two youngsters buddy Prav
and Andy Woodward you see the chess bra
representation there on uh perov sweater
so I I have no idea who I'm cheering for
in this match up
James yeah definitely a hard one there
wow we got chess bra I see him with the
chess bra hoodie on flexing it there and
then you got Andy ready to go the kid is
locked in right and that's his locked in
face believe it or not cuz he just has
the same face ring all the time but the
kid is definitely a for Speed rcking we
this is probably the most heated and and
heavy anticipated matchup in the entire
event not even with Ray in it it's these
two right here the newcomers of course
and the younger uh younger crowd younger
generation so it's going to be excellent
and fun to see the match up here yeah we
got Ray sitting there in the Grand Final
waiting to see who he's going to go up
against and Andy Woodward and perov are
competing the losers bracket which means
it will be a best of four once again and
the winner moves on to play Jeffrey Jong
so it's not like they go straight to the
final Jeffrey Jong is going to be
sitting and waiting for his opportunity
to make it back to the final and and
what would be a rematch for him against
Ray in fact I'm thinking now and Prav
has also been against Ray so these guys
are looking for that next opportunity
and Andy the number one seed coming into
this day uh James he's uh he's not
looking to exit this quickly he's not
looking to exit quickly at all here in
fact as Andy Ward is a force to be
reckoned with Prav being the same I
think he's a wild card a dark horse in
fact the one that like no one even
considered to do anything here they like
buddy who is that Prav what who is and
then they like oh he's going to win it
is can he win it it's all different now
it's all different yeah I mean one thing
that you have to one thing you have to
give to Prav is that he did the best
against Ray out of anybody so you know
Jeffrey Jeong amazing run in the winners
bracket but against Ray he didn't really
put that pressure that Prav did we're
going to jump into the match right now
Prav against Andy both got it what is
what is oh man wait till you guys see it
I don't know what what was this one to
got wrong bro yeah they they both had
the same you know they saw the same
things and they didn't see the same
things sometimes it's like that you know
have you ever played a a match James or
maybe people in the chat I know I have
where you hang a queen and they don't
see it it's like you both just missed
the exact same thing at the exact same
time at the exact same time correct and
you both think you know oh that was mate
and we both like oh wait it wasn't
mate it wasn't a minute and a half and
both guys pretty much at 40 so there you
go that's that pace you were talking
about
James yeah looks great 40 right under
minute 30 the pace is on 450 but they
need to be careful as they're using
their time very nice and pav first to
crack it there that's a tough 42 puzzle
not very tough with E4 93 at the end
yeah cuz it's it's kind of like just a
check and then the F2 Pawn is hanging
both guys took a long time on that one
takes takes take takes okay that's good
good take take take T up
easy
easy oh he got that wrong Bishop F5 yeah
Bishop
F5 that's a good
one 47 48 though
Prav with one extra X that's right and
with that 30 seconds taking down that's
really
really going to matter oh there's the
second X okay it's close guys exactly we
were expecting
5150 yep best of four so it's going to
be very very quick here this is the only
match that we have on going at the
moment so we will be focusing right
here
53 54 kid wow forv got it too open but
55 comes in you're not with the buzzer
at the buzzer
who get off me the definition of a
buzzer beater and I believe he's going
to save that draw at the end holy a tie
to start things off this is going to be
an exciting one oh I've done that before
doesn't that feel good when you get that
buzzer beater and that's a 55 buzzer
beater so it feels even better if I'm
Prav in the chess BR hoodie I'm amp now
I don't want that to happen again but
I'm definitely Ed exactly it's like a
you don't want to be in that position
but hey but we're still we're still
going to make the best out of it we're
still going to make the best out of it
so and then uh yeah Andy just wants to
get all green there just stay focused
and locked in from Andy clutch for sure
and you know as many as many Spectators
as we have here in the crowd watching
this we actually have two more
Spectators as well Ray and Jeffrey are
both going to be keenly watching the
proceedings at the moment they're
wondering you know who I got to watch
out for who I got to watch out for and
Ray is recovering stretching the hands
and the wrists and the fingers you know
the ergonomic exercises and then you
know get some lunch and then coming back
and getting ready getting ready the man
has a easy job until uh maybe uh some
time once this is up go R what up Joe
Bru in chat go Andy says justess you
chess with you Christoph for you in chat
what's up
chat there we go there we go
there star studed chat right here and I
mean what a run by both of these guys
right here we talk about 40 out of
minute 30 how about 40 out of minute
45 for oh that's very nice very very
nice very hot 40 just under a minute 40
as well All Greens yeah this is going to
be a heated one let's see if they touch
a 60 I feel a 60 do you feel a 60 here
what you think bro geez I'm I'm calling
you know 56 I'm going 56 I'm call I'm
actually calling 58 I'm feeling 5 I Ain
really feeling a 60 here but I'm feeling
8ish well you you got a good shot there
with 47 from Andy Woodward at this point
48 nothing wrong and that that gives you
that confidence like when you're just
when you're flowing like that look at
that 50 before a minute All Greens 50
46 51 okay work work work
MH got one wrong there that is going to
bite him Andy oh
same
dang and he got
the wrong whoa breathe Andy yeah going a
little bit quick there now the
pressure's
on oh pavf stuck though prf yeah so the
thing is Pav's got that extra X but not
anymore he got the same one
wrong same one think got to move yeah I
think I think Andy got this one Andy oh
that's it 55 but I mean 20 seconds to
get four in this range is very hard
possible very
52 If he if he does oh out wrong there
yeah that's as you said it's just a lot
to ask with time taking down like that
to to get 56 would be a lot yeah yeah
that's too much 55 seems to be the score
right that was the score in the first uh
match that they did another 55 I mean
how do you take out Andy Woodward when
he's going 55 55 555 55 like 55 yeah you
got any fives on you yeah I got them all
right here 55s 55s
everywhere well this is potentially
match point right because Andy Woodward
wins he gets two and a half points
remember this is a best of four four so
it goes real quick here very fast this
could be the final game or we may have
another but then well actually yeah
that' be tie breaks after next no
possible I feel like at this point if
you're putting up 55s every single time
like that type of consistency he's got
to be good enough you know right right
yeah right 55 like come on bro I'm doing
55s this guy can't beat me like
how what
else what what can I do it just wasn't
my day
man that's funny 30 before two I mean
these guys are both on great
Pace very very quick ah his rating look
at that feature chat there and he also
has the 5 5555 number wow dang I like
that symbolic from Andy here I wonder if
he do that on purpose he like yeah I can
do 60 but I'm waiting for good call good
call from the chat there it's
nice 40 he's opening up a lead as Prav
just can't figure that puzzle out there
oh got the wrong King E7 that's stupid I
guess can have seven they won it yeah
but it's winning by like an extra plus
two
that's how it feels you know whenever
you get it wrong it's like ah man let's
check that puzzle again coach coach's
Challenge and it says like oh yeah yeah
yeah you were right but this one's
better by only half half a
margin okay thanks okay 48 right
now just I mean this is more than a 55
Pace from Andy
Woodward if I'm going to talk about one
of the skills that I think Prav has it's
those ones at the end he's kind of like
Ray in that way where maybe he's not the
fastest early on but and he can do those
tough ones quickly I'm a fan of that I
think uh I like to have the speed I like
to have the healthy balance of course
you just have the the good speed but you
also are calculating when it really
matters there later on when you're
faster when it's later that's what
really counts not the uh the easy ones
we talked about Andy putting up 55s well
he he's got 55 with 30 seconds remain 30
60 more what you trying to do Andy what
you trying to do Andy you trying to do a
60 and this is for the win right now
right that's 5654 both guys playing out
of their minds there this is a must-win
type
situation 55 oh he is close the oh one
wrong there 57 is crazy eight oh he got
crazy 59
do move away from 59 Andy Woodward that
is incredible look at the numbers he put
up when it mattered in an elimination
game 55 55 and what 57 58 in fact 58 I'm
averaging 55 let's just say
that I'm averaging
55 that's the face of a young competitor
that just put up one of his best runs
ever right that those numbers like we
were saying how do you lose a match by
putting up those numbers like it's
impossible it's impossible unless you're
facing Ray who does 10 more than your
high right is impossible to try to crush
but it's very doable and Andy is trying
to make it happen but one guy steps in
his way right now who is that among yeah
we're going to bring up the bracket let
you know exactly what's going on right
now because with that win Andy Woodward
moves on and will be facing Jeffrey Jong
will be the only match up coming before
the Grand Final the winner of this moves
on to face Ray we're going to take at
extremely extremely short break and just
get this match set up for you but we
will be straight back with Andy Woodward
against Jeffrey Jong in the puzzle World
[Music]
Championship I can guarantee that
working your way through this course and
solving all 1,1 exercises will reward
you not only with a greater tactical
knowledge but also with spotting more
tactics in your own games my name is
fion dantony and I'm a woman
International master I wish you a warm
welcome to the chus 101 chess exercises
for beginners authored by Franco mati
and Roberto Mesa with videos by me in
this case the Knight on C5 is not
protected and so the winning move is G6
G6 is the discovered attack but it is
also a double attack because not only
are we hitting the Knight on C5 we are
also threatening mate on H7 in this case
Rook C7 black has no choice but to
capture and now our Queen comes in we've
lured the queen away now the king is too
far removed it cannot protect the black
queen so we are going to pick up the
black queen on the next move
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more chess.com SL events has all of the
top chess tournaments played both over
the board and online analyze and review
games from the world's greatest players
with live commentary cloud analysis
opening Explorer and table bases find
all the key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more even
compete by voting for your predicted
results explore chess.com events today
on web or with our IOS and Android apps
and experience chess like never
before
[Music]
you
he
[Music]
back here at the puzzle World
Championship on your screen Grand Master
Jeffrey Shong he is playing currently in
the losers final against Andy Woodward
kind of flying under the radar a little
bit this event James but let's talk a
little bit more about Jeffrey Mr consist
he's been doing so well in this
competition and he's the 20 2016 World
Junior Champion but here he is excelling
in Puzzles what makes him so good at
puzzles here yeah that's a great
question in fact look at his highest his
3 minute 58 right next to uh Andy there
I mean but of course he just sees the
board very well he's also played you
know us Championship he's won World open
before I've been there seen him when he
won World open I think that was like
2019 or something like that but very
strong player incred strong uh young as
well trains with the best of them I mean
and he loves the game so all the
accolades are there now he's going to
have to face you know a very strong and
very hungry kid here Andy Woodward
that's right getting right into things
Jeffrey Jong against Andy Woodward I
remember you know Jeffrey Jong this is a
guy that I remember playing when he was
even younger I got a win against him
trust me it never happened again after
that and I feel like Andy Woodward is
right at that age such a young
competitor and showing off in Puzzles
right now look for more of him in
Puzzles but also in in the main chest
scene as well wow yeah I mean it's good
to see Andy I've seen him in many
tournaments you know he's a very very
strong kid he's been playing a lot of
Chess also I think he's at the US chess
school as well I mean everything he's
getting it all now even getting the
sponsorship with with Hikaru there that
they mentioned yesterday which is even
fire like the kid is just going to excel
to Heights Beyond you know uh whatever
limit is his type thing right as long as
long as he keeps staying assist so it's
going to be nice to see what he does in
the future too as well future of Chess
there through Andy Woodward no
absolutely you said it and seeming so uh
so mature with how he's handling the
pressure in this event so far uh that's
going to serve him well in in everything
in life um but definitely in this in
this competition right now as we see
he's opening up what looks like a
tremendous first round here against
Jeffrey Jeff Jeff is not cooking right
now in fact there something happened he
got two wrong there that's going to be a
very detrimental feat there in this
short match here it's only two and a
half if okay it's four games or eight
eight games you know four and a half
wins a match say at least that's going
to give you a little bit of leeway to be
able to make these type of mistakes but
here it's very crucial it's not looking
good already in the first match for Chef
CHF that's
right yeah 40 uh Jeffrey though I've
been saying he's he is so consistent
like I haven't seen either of these guys
really put up up one of those super low
scores so Jeff needs to focus up here
and you know get get that get that up to
50 oh my goodness it's already over
claim commentator curse again yeah
that's that's a rough round for Chef
Jeff and you know Andy putting up 50
every round has he not I mean it's been
50 since day one like it has since the
first of the year it's been 50 every
time I don't think he's uh he's failed
to put up a 50 yet and of course right
when I talk about how consistent Jeffrey
is he's like yeah let me put up the
lowest number in the entire event for me
so far he's going to lose that first
game and it is a best of four we're
still in the losers final here so just
always want to remind everybody that two
and a half points it happens quickly Cy
it does in fact because I mean hey we
have another run like that or not as
good or we don't get a 50 I mean imagine
that like you have to score 50 against
Andy you literally have to do it or you
you lose so you have to score 50 plus
here you know and hopefully you can do
that which he can he just has to you
know pull this together here and
hopefully play his best here because
this again is a short match two and a
half wins exactly you know if you're if
you're Prav from last round you had to
score 56 if you even wanted to sniff a
win against
Andy yeah that's a win that's a smells
like a win
hopefully all right so what's the pace
looking like here Jeffrey I've noticed
has consistently been behind Andy on the
early Pace but kind of picks it up at
the end Andy uh I guess it makes sense
just those younger competitors I feel
like they do those early ones like
nothing like half a second he's barely
even processing
them 30 look at that man he's up this is
nice he's opening up a lead here I like
the consistency and the pace I think he
reminds me of uh of Ray how Jeffrey does
puzzles here it's not as fast exactly
but he definitely gets it done and he
gets the high numbers in the rushes I
think Andy's like a combination of like
both it's like fast and he like hold on
man how do you do both of these buddy
yep yeah it's it's hard for me at the
moment to name someone who has a faster
initial Pace than Andy because even Ray
I think he outpaces Ry on the first to
30 first to 40 uh marks but then later
on things can catch up to him yeah you
can catch up I think Ray has a very
great ability to do that later oh snap I
was about to say this is what we're
talking about the early speed from Andy
but later on you know that consistency
from Jeffrey does catch him up yeah
takes takes check there it is but 45 I
mean these leads he always has a lead
which is nice and he he stretches the
lead and keeps you like having to move
fast timely keeps you under pressure
that's the word there's a lot of
pressure you get from playing Andy
that's
right consistency from Jeffrey Jong
coming in again but it doesn't feel like
having that those two x's really phases
Andy he's just he just cycling through
these like it's nothing I like I
shouldn't slow down I am in the 50s here
this was Bishop F that doesn't
work I mean what do you do oh okay Rich
one nice beautiful B 52 check check
takes got him two wrong for both of
these guys 5351 super close
though Andy still looking in spots it is
he gonna hit his coveted 55 again 55 has
been his number
but it does I don't yeah you need you
need to do two puzzles in two seconds
here we go oh yeah it's a here's
55 so impressive he's hitting that
number Time come on come on I got a 53
bro I can't win with a 53 come on bro
you can't even
tie wow two nothing for Andy and
speaking of the tie there's only a half
Point needed from Andy
here it looks like it's going to be a
Andy and a r show and you know what
those are the first two seeds right it's
it was Andy Woodward coming in the first
seed coming into today's event Ray
second seed based on qualification
yesterday but obviously I think everyone
knows here the the favorite to win as he
has been in the past but um Andy against
Ray is a matchup that we have not
witnessed yet and I cannot wait if
that's the case Jeffrey he's not ready
to exit just yet James je Jeff says wait
a second hold on y'all C me out already
well of course it does take you do need
to win three right now in a row which is
gonna be hard to do in fact and it's on
it's best of four in fact so maybe two
you have to win the next two and then is
there a tie break there they have to do
just the regular tie break like yeah the
tie breaks are done exactly like what uh
what was done with Hans and they'll add
up I believe First is the cumulative
scores and uh sadly to say if I'm
looking at them right now that 41 from
Jeff
that's not going to help that
much yeah so even on tie breaks I mean
is this just like inevitable I'm just
lost like even if I get to two ex I'm
losing on tie breaks so why am I I'm out
I'm just all right shoot peace bro like
hey see you in the final like what are
we doing here yeah Andy I think would
have to have a real poor uh round but
you know these guys aren't thinking
about those uh types of things right now
they're just taking the puzzles one at a
time and you know the best position you
can put yourself in right now is a
tiebreak so that's what Jeffrey is going
to try to do yeah he's going to try to
do it anyway of course Finn is strong as
much as you can very great showing from
both players of course Andy just being
very impressive here first year here
making it uh close to the final here
it's not over yet but it definitely
looks very Bleak here for for Jeffrey
4745 minute left he's just running
through him and he just oh got it
wrong
yeah but they both have two x's right
now oh out of there he's out of there
opportunity he's got to be perfect
though he's going to get it he he has
time so he should really you know make
sure bang I believe he's got it right
now right that's it that's that's a one
that's a one but I think again tie
breaks would allow even with a loss here
but he just attempted that
puzzle so he lost yeah wait you know
what that is confusing there this is
what I mean I don't I don't know like am
I the only one that understands the
format here like why did he attempt that
puzzle oh my goodness unless I'm missing
something it's absolutely insane to
attempt that puzzle you're right because
it just would
have just take the
win
claim the win how many times we said
that today claim the win that's why it's
there what claim
it that's a disappointing way to go out
and you know ties do exist so that's a
half point and it is a best of four so
Andy Woodward advances off that yeah but
it must have been more for like increase
the
score to try to better increase the tie
break score but you're only going to
have a tiebreak score to increase if
if you get the win yeah yeah if we get
the win that's correct okay so yeah you
know there's obviously it's not totally
insane but I just think getting that win
is is worth more than risking going out
but um you know obviously easy to say in
hindsight James regardless that is going
to be a win for Andy Woodward two and a
half to half he does get it done let's
have a look at that bracket uh James as
we do see that match conclude let's take
a look
look at that we have finally set things
up for the most exciting match seed
number one and two give me your thoughts
right now James as we finally have our
grand final Ray Robson Andy Woodward
you've seen them battle throughout this
competition what do you make of the two
players as they go head-to-head let me
tell you something this could be an all
day match and you know why I say this is
cuz we said this in the beginning of the
stream last night guess who was playing
and I'm streaming at 9900 p.m. you know
eastern time and I think it was around
10ish p.m. eastern time and these guys
Ray and Andy we playing Puzzle Battle
Andy was in my chat Andy like hey K you
I'm playing Ray right now I'm like we're
going to stop everything we're doing and
we're going to go watch y'all play and
he played I mean I don't know how many
games they played but we watched them
play and now we're going to see it again
live in front of all you guys here so
Andy I'm sure is ready Ray is ready this
is the match we've all been waiting for
absolutely and you know I I do have to
say before we get all caught up in our
puzzles want to remind people that
there's something else upcoming that we
can get excited for it that's the 2024
Tata steel tournament and it begins
tomorrow January 13th so join us as we
cover that classical action with players
like world champion dangly Ren women's
world champion ju Jun pragnan Nanda and
so many more tune in to chess 24 streams
tomorrow that's 8:00 a.m. eastern time
and you guys can all do exclamation mark
Tata in chat to read up on the event
just had to let the people know that you
know while we're puzzling there is some
very exciting classical chess happening
but now I'm done with that James back to
the puzzles here come on now back to the
puzzles we're going to see a lot of that
in the tat Ste that's going to be fun
but hey we got a big match coming up
guys this is about to be epic on yeah
Ray against Andy and I think the most
exciting thing about this this one is
that we haven't seen it so far it's just
been teased you know uh we're expecting
that this might happen like if coming in
if I had to predict uh what the final
would look like it would probably be
this the only thing that I want to
remind everybody about is that Rey has
not lost which means if he loses against
Andy they're doing a reset so Andy
Woodward has to win two times against
Ray not only does he have to win all
those individual B win a match he's got
to do it twice what do you think oh yeah
thanks oh man okay well you know at
first I'm like oh yeah I got a shot then
you like I got to do it twice okay wait
a second here buddy can we first off go
no can we not do that like why do we
have to do it two times why does it have
to be twice wow hey double elimination
got to keep it fair Ray hasn't lost at
all yet so makes sense he's got to have
those two lives remaining see them on
cam there the experienced the veteran
four-time Champion Ray Rob goes by spicy
caterpillar as the nickname we're going
to get into a spicy match up here as the
kid the youngster Andy is going up
against him here look at that look look
at the stats I can't get over that 69
are we going to see more 60 bombs how
many 60 bombs are you calling for Ray
Robinson in the finals I mean that was
crazy probably to I mean this is the
whole another ray if you see that that
level up this is the time right here I
mean y'all can't see him but off screen
right now Ray got his eyes closed I
don't know what he doing he like
meditating or like he like tapping into
another realm it's scary look at him
like it's scary to go to see just hit a
60 in his head right
now head with his eyes closed my
goodness and then opened up that man is
about to go off but Andy is has a lot to
proof too as well so it's exciting to
see the games are about to start guys
yeah let's get right back into this
matchup Andy Ray the Grand Final that
people have been waiting for excited for
for I think what I'm looking for is Andy
to get off to that early Pace that he
seems to have set this entire
competition he has been faster than even
the likes of Ray so let's see if he can
do that here and speak of the devil look
at that just ahead of Ray in that early
Pace James just the hey and as we saw
this yesterday too as well now I did see
this is kind of like we was getting a
preview before the match because we saw
Ray and Andy last night it was awesome
watching them play Puzzle Battle and I
did see more often than not Andy got off
to a faster start but again it would be
Ry that in the more challenging ones the
30s the 40s to 50s you would see that
sort of flipflop where Ray was faster
there and Andy was slower naturally as
you know you get these harder puzzles
you need to spend more time in the think
but Ray was kind of flying through those
so we'll see what happens let us let us
know the insights what were you know
what kind of scores did did you see like
who was beating who cuz you have it was
it was 50s it was all 50s all night you
know we start the stream with a clean 50
on Survival All Greens then you know we
we go do three minute five minute puzzle
rush I'm trying to hit 50 you know I'm
in 48s 49s then we watch them boys and
they were doing 50s every time 5050 50
51 54 58 5050 5050 all the time yeah I
feel like if we don't see a 50 from
either of these guys in this Grand Final
that's disappoint that's like a awful
score yeah correct it's like ah it's
disgusting 49 what am I doing it's like
that's my high what am I doing that's
what you're
doing right you know 50s all 50s from
these boys All Greens right now look at
uh Andy though all green ahead of Ray as
I've seen many times yep so I think in
this last minute this is where Ry tends
to excel because it's almost like he
doesn't see the difference between an
easy puzzle and a hard puzzle he just
sees the answer that's a great
observation I think that's exactly
explaining Ray he just sees the puzzle
at all levels at the same rate which is
really nice
of course he does spend a little time to
think here but he doesn't get them wrong
as much and he keeps the same Pace he
spent a little time there got that one
wrong though and this is a good feeling
you know you spend a lot of time on a
puzzle and get it wrong it's the worst
feeling right right like what am I doing
why do I even play this game okay okay
so this is where Ray needs to pick up
the pace 54 to 50 55 he's getting them
like nothing let's go box says he's all
in on Ray in the chat go ahead chat put
your predictions put your predic chat
predict
predict is this GNA be a 60 bomb from
Andy 58 you going with 58 58 59 to hit
him with a 60 on National National
interational Television trying he trying
to hit him with 60 he try to he went 60
didn't get it but that is an amazing
start he just put his best 59 is tied
for his best he almost dropped a 60
piece in the first game in the first
game he trying to he trying to swing on
Ray bro you ever you remember when you
was doing your chess boxing you know and
they just come out swinging at you right
you know that's what Andy's coming out
mean and he's he's Swinging with like
good technique you know he know what
he's doing right now this is so
impressive to watch I mean this is Ray
Robson who just wins this event almost
like a guarantee every year Andy
Woodward coming in this year and saying
no there's a new kid on the Block and
dropping a 59 in game one is a
unbelievable way to start make a
statement he's like in your face bro and
I won and I won buddy yeah uhuh
59 incredible Ray's gonna have to do his
personal best every round you know like
68 just to put him away 60 70s that's
crazy if we a 70 here you that just
count for two runs that well the thing
is I think with a 70 you could add up my
runs and I might
lose I still might lose right add them
up exactly
33 oh you got one wrong somewhere in
there yeah I feel like the consistent
style of Ray you know even Jeffrey more
similar to that um you know they do get
outpaced early but look at the speed
it's it's like one thing to just get
outpaced a little bit and you make it up
later but man 39 from Andy but the
double x oh double back I gotta be
careful here he has to be careful
dropping a 59 and now at 41 here
two
wrong this probably when he got wrong as
Ray leans in he's like what is this he
finds and he takes and he gets it right
that's always a you know little Flex
we've talked about it making sure that
you get the one right that they got
wrong we need that need that to bank up
some time 44 he's catching up catching
up
so a minute left but Andy is going to
have to be just razor perfect with the
rest of his puzzles he doesn't have any
room for error but neither does Ray
anymore pressure on both who's both oh
this one the crazy want Andy on right
now I don't know Queen G2 bro what are
you doing Bishop E3 or queen F2 and take
the Knight what the heck was that but
then Queen F7 M there too many things to
think about in puzzle that's my problem
I'll be like but but then this but then
this but okay but let's see if Ray gets
it because I agree that was a super
tough one it's going to be all on this
puzzle in my opinion if Ray gets this
he's probably going to jump ahead three
strikes he finds
it oh is he gonna find
it it's I think it's a really silence in
everywhere like it's just silent he
finds takes check oh he got a 5 51 but
he's only got seven seconds oh he found
it now he just sit you literally claim
to win
you should sit that's it there you go
you see that that's what you needed to
do there and he gets the no point
attempting that Ray the veteran takes
the win with the tie
score man he got I just exhaled for the
first time I think that entire match
right
that okay that's air that's what air
feels like okay we're good oxygen next
match there we go
there we go there we
go so also remember that this is a best
of eight again we've kind of been
jumping around cuz we watching the
losers bracket but now this is the Grand
Final best of eight which means we are
going to go of course until four and a
half points so keep that Target score in
mind for these two players and even if
Andy Woodward beats Ray guess what he's
got to set the pieces back up and do it
one more time all right bro you want to
do it again I no really I don't really
want to fight you again but okay I guess
I have to in fact already won once like
now I got to do it again okay very
difficult man what a puzzle um these are
the easier ones so far yeah yeah
quotation easier easier you still can
get some
wrong and look at the difference between
uh the first game and this one when you
look at those scores it was almost six
for Andy and then the second time around
much closer to 50 those guys barely got
above 50 so much different runs it
always depends based on the puzzles you
get that's right yeah sometimes I think
I call it batches batches of puzzles
like sometimes you'll know like on move
three when they want you to do a deeski
page 181 on like the fifth puzzle you're
like oh yeah this is gonna be a crazy
run like something's wrong let me
sometimes I'll stop and just do a whole
another run because like this one's
going to be whack well we've seen a win
from both guys so far I got to ask the
chat who do you guys have to win this
first match here is Ray going to win the
whole thing right now or is Andy G to
force the reset the bracket reset
against Ray Robson because it's one to
one right now and we've seen the highest
score posted in the entire match so far
by Andy
Woodward Chad what's the highest score
you think we gonna see today too as well
who do you think is going to win and
what's the highest puzzle ref score do
you think
are we going to get a
60 59 was out there first game like it
was nothing meanwhile these guys
both they're they're uh both at 50 here
and that was the score they pretty much
got last round so with a minute to spar
and all the X's for
Ray let see what he can do let's see it
let's see it we got a lot of Andes in
chat okay Ray Ray 64s 60s 70s 63s okay
chat some people
calling the name as well what about Andy
at 57 right now he is eyeballing that's
60 piece oh and
up okay does he have this one
58 Ray on a perfect run but it's just
not not close to 58 right now he's got
to speed up oh yeah he got that R he's
got to speed up now come on Andy Andy
swinging 59 swinging come on get off 60
59 again 59 bro that's nasty dude that's
nasty 59 two of them against R hey bro
hey chill Andy you gotta chill man 59 is
just insane two to one for Andy Woodward
he's posted his personal best twice now
in the finals like if you could say that
you were going to get your personal best
James and it's like uh where would you
like it uh maybe round one or should you
save it for the grand finals like yeah
I'll take it in the finals please take
it in the finals yeah I'll take it in
the finals against Ray in front of
everybody
59 and we were kind of joking about
scoring 56 78 and maybe still losing to
Ray the exact opposite is happening Ry
is posting 56 Ray is posting 57 and he's
losing to Andy's
59s and 50 yeah 59s them them some big
those are big numbers very big numbers
there and Ray Robson did Ray Robson did
a 60 the two days ago I think something
like that but they says he just he just
casually warmed up with it it is
different when you have someone else
you're playing against to as well when
you're sitting there by yourself but he
did just drop a 60 I know recently he
just had he needs to out now he did it
today just in an earlier match I think
it was oh that's what it was okay no or
something TR to remember but yeah he he
dropped a 60 already so he dropped a 60
today okay okay nice need's to bring
that 60 out again here Andy hit these
59s Andy's about to drop a
60 the commentator curse again he's got
two
wrong this basically at the same Pace
right now as usual Andy a little bit
ahead but those two x's I think you'd
rather be in rais position here yeah
100% oh got that one okay feeling better
hold on get that other one wrong too
that he got wrong such an interesting
moment when both players as good as they
are just miss the exact same thing it's
also very awesome to see as good as Ray
is I mean Andy up you know healthy
amount four four I'm up three four to
wrong you know talk to me talk to me
Aman what's going on baby it's amazing
the way that Andy is able to just keep
his composure take the puzzles one at a
time even when he's got those two x's so
impressive 52 he keeping that steady
lead and that as the time gets lower
that matters a lot more the little small
lead that I have that I accumulated if I
can stay consistent Stay Focus keep
calculating
well and he's leaning in he's really
thinking on this one Rook G5 and takes
oh my goodness 54 check
55 yeah I think Andy got this one too
bro I think Andy has this one it feels
feels good 5356 you need three more 20
seconds so insane
57 he's out of there he's out of there
he is out of there so this is where you
don't claim the win now you keep going
cuz your tiebreak score might matter so
absolutely keep going will this be the
60 bomb another 59 no
58 look at that young player right there
Andy Woodward on cam and he is feeling
it right now up three to one on Ray
Robson the defending champ yeah he's
just dropping 58 59 is like it's nothing
it's like hey you know you know I am
having a nice day right right big way
have a nice day he like I am how's yours
you know it's great actually great as
Yer as yaser San likes to say was it as
good for you as it was for me yes it was
Christian yes very good hey you didn't
tell the the folk that you were uh
working on a stellar Yasser impression
in the back you know yes back in 1965 I
did impressions for Bobby and it was uh
a little bit different when I would take
bonds then what about
you it reminds me of my old friend Le
boir lubo we called him ah lubo I know
him yes yes shout out to yaser pong
Grabber extraordinaire but uh while
we've been yapping in yaser speak it's
actually Andy was two wrong before
what up just in chat what's up baby
what's good y oh looking bad looking
bad yeah actually should be in Charlotte
tonight oh man I'm sorry I couldn't make
it out there dang that'd be nice
Charlotte Fire nitki Yer and nitki and
it's a tournament out
there low key you know where where's
nitki unfortunately the guy must be uh
must be busy otherwise I feel he could
do some damage in an event like this he
was in the chat yesterday said that in
fact flying out or something like that
flying to uh to I guess to well no he's
in Charlotte so yeah doing something he
just like yeah I couldn't make it blah
blah blah bad timing that happens Dam
two others said the same so it happens
okay how many F yesterday sadly there it
is yeah how many have we got in a row
almost 15 for um Andy and I mean it's
like I'm talking about that being in a
row meanwhile it's 47 in a row 48 for
Ray but the reason I mentioned Andy is
because he's got those two strikes so
he's playing a little bit slower than he
usually is and Ray is working here Ray
is bouncing back man I mean is this a r
60 piecey this feeling like a ray 60
piece oh three out three and out this is
actually quite relevant because that 47
with three X's means Ray can run up the
score for the tibs is actually a big
deal here
52 okay we trying to do a 60p is getting
shorter so I'm thinking
57 26 seconds ra locked in right
now trying to stay locked in calculating
and calculate and and found
54 jeez for the ray fans everywhere you
can say you can feel better you can
breathe exhale ah breathe exhale inhale
through the nose the mouth you get
you're good right get to the so 56 to 47
it's 56 is a great score but it's the
difference that 47 tie break- wise could
really hurt that is the lowest score
that's been posted oh yeah forgot about
the tie breaks part that's crazy yeah
the tie breaks that could definitely
hurt but there is more life here more
life Ray is able to stay here this is
very critical for Ray as he needs to put
up a very nice performance here if Andy
can consistently can do that 59 again
this can be looking very bad as he moves
to four and then four and a half wins
the whole thing but then you have to
beat him
again right it's the reset that sucks
man like just hurts you know all that
energy just to beat him once just to do
it again yeah for example like these 59s
that he's posting he might post a bunch
of 59s and maybe still not even win this
match that's incredible man that is
incredible that is incredible to put in
perspective dropping 59 feeling like a
boss you know walking around ah like you
just dunked on somebody you're feeling
great and then you you know you still
lose the match it's possible to still
lose the match it says Whoa something
wrong oh my goodness o I don't know if
his nerves or something but it is not
looking good for Andy that round
wow so if you look at the scores what's
interesting to me is that you've got 59
59 58 some huge score oh my good you
talk about tie breaks they're out the
window right now I think officially Andy
cannot let Ray get to Four Points
because this is cooked on tys that's the
three piece that is a three piece
already for Ray here and of course as he
extends the lead with a minute and 30
that is going to ruin the tie breaks
100% as he's going to run this boy up to
the 50 ball with a minute and 30 already
and he's just kind of chilling and
coasting the pressure's off which means
he can this could be a 60 run because
the pressure's off I can take some time
it's just good point now it's like he's
just on stream chilling you know
chilling right Feeling Good Feeling Good
Feeling Good feeling better I could be
feeling you know much even much better
here after this run so we will
see yeah so this is all R it is going to
be 33 we know that but the tie breaks
are going to be just completely in Ray
favor um so I don't think that's even a
consideration and what that means is
that if Ray gets four points I think I
think that's it you know so Andy has to
win the next one or at least tie it
right at least tie it yeah at least tie
it regardless incredible run for Andy
this is the final by the way guys the
Grand Final so you have to understand
whatever happens Andy has proved himself
to be an extraordinary not only player
as we already know for this title in the
ACC
but definitely has he been able to take
on Ray Robson the greatest Puzzler in
the last four years in this event
winning it every single time Andy has
been taken it to him very
nice and the I was just pointing out
that the way that he's won has been his
huge scores 58 like 59 59 but the way
that he's lost
47 the 33 you know so he has the highest
but also the lowest
yeah that's a 20 that's a 20 ball there
which is really going to tear up the tie
breaks in fact there are none so no
there's no tie breaks are going to help
Andy here and if he can put that
together then he knows that he cannot
lose this game right
here here we go lock in Chad this is
very important tie three to three what
do you think is going to happen you know
what a big shout out to Andy and Prav
because Prav did the same thing this was
33 I mean it's almost you know in a way
but and yeah Andy had a lead pav had a
leave where was able to take it so
reminiscent of the same story here but
the kids the the um the newcomers into
this Championship here or into this
whole format were great they made it
very far and definitely challenged Ray
totally and even if Ray just wins this
competition again I think he's going to
be winning it with a much different
feeling he's like okay you know there's
a fire under me I feel I feel the the
the competitors are out to get me next
time they on me exactly they're on me I
need to step it up this year you know
whatever I gotta do because they're
coming for
me he exact same Pace right now 2
minutes over 30 guys are doing
fantastic this is more of an Andy run
you know I think Andy does Excel when he
doesn't have those early oh my
goodness doesn't have those that was you
bro that was on you that was completely
you couldn't even finish the sentence
bro God damn it well let me let me
switch over to Ray and do the same thing
just to make it even you know I think
Ray excels here when he doesn't have
those early mistakes you know that's
where Ry really does well no mistakes
right right I see I seem to have lost it
dang lost it instantly it just comes and
goes crazy it just like comes and goes
like that oh and another there it is
okay it was delayed it was delayed just
to cook the tie breaks completely I
think you know this this is another
really low score so um yeah even I I
think even if Ry loses the next one the
tiebreak should be way too much to
overcome unless Ry basically doesn't
enter the next race you know yeah
exactly if he just like turns off the
computer or you know dips out dang man
what uh what a way to go out here Andy
though he did put up those monster
performances 59 it happens what was I
saying like up a 59 and maybe still take
the ls it's insane yeah still very
possible yeah 52 now I mean TI Brees are
done so they have one more seven games
yeah and then we have one more he has to
win which yeah that's just
over but I think there is a difference
uh to winning and losing on the tie
breaks and having Ray win 5-3 and I
think both of these players will feel a
difference in that as well so I still
think it's gonna be a competitive uh
last game here that's right n sanss in
chat says imagine if Ray scores five in
round eight okay that's possible now
that is a that's a you know possibility
don't know what universe but it will be
imag I'm picturing it okay I'm done
picturing
it it went just like that how about a 57
from Ray that's a
57 57 just to cement that tiebreak
situation we're into what is going to be
the last
game Andy Woodward he was up three to
one and Ray just came back surging three
wins in a row crazy to think he was a
3-1 dang you just can't look at that
from a pych standpoint or you have to
emotion standpoint like three to one is
you know that's that's beefy you get
that two you on almost a three- game
lead you know and he's able to make it
now basically almost the other way
around it doesn't matter how you get it
it matters if you get it done that's
right and it it just feels like the arc
kind of he started at the 59 59 58 but
then his next scores 47 33 41 not good
enough in the the Grand Final against
Ray Robson unfortunately that's crazy
how you could just be such you know a
beast on the front end there and then
three not even terrible scores I mean
you know for for his standard yes but
also like those aren't terrible scores
to for you the match is just over after
that which is crazy that small of a
margin it
is got one wrong there but he's he's
just going for Pure speed not slowing
down for
nothing well I guess uh R and he didn't
score he scored a little bit more than
five here so look like time breaks will
not be in Andy's favor at
all
let's see here he's got one wrong but I
feel like Ray being even at this point
is kind of good because he's he's
actually been uh behind most of the
time yeah he definitely has and I've
seen that in fact every year believe it
or not I always notice and I've learned
this from Ray to as well is you know you
like to implement you know what Ray does
obviously in all these puzzle solvers
but Ry does not like he he just doesn't
get them wrong as much and he does he
takes his time he really takes his time
he's very patient with it really like to
see that really like to see how he does
his puzzles so it's important some tough
ones there slowing the players
down what the heck is that Queen takes
E5 oh it was
whoa
impressive every year nice spot there
from Andy the finals 46 46 on the same
puzzles and and that is going to be it
no tie breaks needed Ray I feel like
he's the type of guy to just keep
puzzling his way out he's not here to
claim a win yeah so yeah yeah yeah he
doesn't claim the win congratulations to
Andy anyway but uh congrats to Ray again
have to extend uh hearty congratulations
to to Andy Woodward for making this
final so close because it it's easy to
just be like like okay Ray's in the
tournament you know pack it up but
incredible by Andy to make it close but
ultimately was it ever going to be
anything different Ray Robson your
four-time Champion is now your five time
Champion puzzle world champion right on
your screen right there James five in a
row bro that's just just you know you
feeling like Magnus a puzzles you're
like yeah you know magna's cool but I'm
R you're like oh Ray Robson theight
lifetime like puzzle world champion yeah
that's me that's me I would take that
and we very heavy as well chess K can
you'all get him like a real can we get a
TR what's that thing nfts yeah the nft
trophy like the chess champion chess
tour can we get one to my man's you know
I'd like to point out to like to point
out James that at the moment Ray Robson
is a world champion and Magnus Carlson
is
not current I'm just gonna say drop the
mic it's out there it's clipped it's in
the internet now 100% you know there
magnus's been real quiet since Ray won
that's all I'm going to say that's all
I'm going to say let's have a look at
the bracket so we can make it
official it's Ray Robson he's going to
be on top he's your Champion man this
has been a great day 5 to three is the
official final score there between Ray
and Andy no tie breaks needed and uh you
know we said so many good things over
the the competition about both these
competitors but any final thoughts uh
James when you think of Ray Robson you
know his journey to the finals and then
Andy making you so competitive you know
what uh I I think this was the first or
second year when I just dubbed the name
big Ray having have a nice day when
Ray's in the room it's hope that's just
what happens he does it time and time
again and it's he does it he did it
again that's what else can you say he
came he delivered he's five-time
Champion here I mean maybe he just
doesn't play like Magnus and just like I
don't want like until he get get some
real competition in fact he did here I
don't want to play anymore no but Jokes
Aside he played a lot of strong
competition this year and he probably
will step it up for the next stepping it
up that's crazy we'll see you know but
congrats to the players that played to
as well he's such a young player that I
know we'll see him back in Future
competitions it's now like a who can
Dethrone Ray Robson in the puzzle World
Championship speaking of Ray uh we are
going to have him on for an interview
which is very exciting hear his thoughts
you know what a what a competition must
be exhausted all that puzzling but we're
going to get that set up and we'll be
right back here at the puzzles World
Championship with an interview with your
your winner Ray Robson just after this
[Music]
break in this video I'm going to show
you top five scholar made attempts in
Champions games before we dive into the
games I would like to show you the
pattern if you have not seen it yet well
this happen happens when white goes with
1 E4 black responds with E5 and white
plays Queen to H5 this queen gets into
the game way too fast attacks the pawn
on E5 now black plays Knight to C6
guarding the pawn and white goes with
Bishop to C4 White's two pieces are
attacking on F7 and would like to
capture this pawn and if black is
careless and plays Knight to F6 then we
have Queen to if7 and this is a
Checkmate Scholars made attempt two by
Hikaru here we have this game between
Hikaru and Philip of anon and we have
one4 E5 Queen goes on H5 and G6 once
again he Carl Queen to F3 once again
gives a try to Checkmate black king
black says no I see that and Knight to
E2 we have seen already this kind of
position earlier in the first game so
black plays Bishop to G7 to make sure
that King is castled and here Hikari
goes with D3 black responds with D5
attacks right away in the center white
captures this pawn and black goes with
Knight to B4 the pawn on C2 is hanging
so white has to play Bishop to B3 to
guard this pawn and now we have Knights
to D5 and here we have this end game
where white has very active pieces both
Rooks are controlling the open files and
the bishop is controlling in this
diagonal as you can see here those
pieces are concentrated mainly on the
queen side and they are not actually so
active and the king is all the way here
on the king side just alone so white is
using this and plays Rook to E7 gives a
check if King goes on the back rank it
will be a Checkmate uh so black goes to
King H6 now and here we have Rook to D6
the pawn is hanging and it's not just a
Pawn it's going to be a Checkmate so
King goes back on G5 plays G6 to guard
the pawn and we have Bishop to C4
attacking The Rook but what is actually
the idea of this move is that white
wants to play Bishop to D3 and Checkmate
this King next
move there we go this is the Checkmate
that happened in this game and second
attempt of Scholars made in fact worked
out this game has ended in 9 moose it
was not a Checkmate in for moose but I
think white got really nice play on the
king
[Music]
side
there
[Music]
he
welcome back the puzzles world
championship and we're here with your
puzzles world champion five times winner
now Grand Master Ray Robson Ray
obviously I got to start with a hearty
congratulations and I'm just going to
ask what did you think of the event is
this the strongest uh field that you've
ever seen you've played in this event so
many times won it so many times what did
you think of the
field yeah I think for sure this year
was the the strongest um I think just
the some of especially the younger
players maybe they weren't playing as
much in previous years but there are
like several of them who are all became
really good I guess within the past year
so that provided like a lot of tough
competition congratulations Ray five
times in a row here so for the six1 and
a competition getting stiffer here of
course somebody's gonna try to take you
out they definitely looking for it so
what are you what are you going to do in
the next year to maybe obviously try to
train and also maybe try to keep a
little distance in between you and the
rest are you
back uh
I don't know yes oh hey do you mind
joining that link that's in the in the
chat call sorry I think I was still in
the other meeting
um yeah uh it's keeping distance yeah I
mean I think it's gonna be hard I would
have to like probably continue to
practice a lot which I mean I enjoy
doing but I think eventually some of
these guys are going to be uh either
surpassed me or like very close to my
level anyway so I it's going to happen
at some point so um I'll still try to
maintain around the same level but I
also like want to prioritize regular
chests so I think I want to put most of
my focus on
that well that's fair keeping the
priorities straight but still taking
first place in the competition on the
side I'm going to go back to that grand
finals match uh Ray I mean how nervous
were you I'm just going to ask you it
was 3-1 Andy was posting 59 59 58 I mean
were you just thinking at that point
like you're going to have to drop 60s
non-stop to beat this
kid yeah that was that was definitely
pretty unnerving um the good thing is I
we've played we practiced a little bit
in the past few days before the
tournament so I knew how good he was and
I know that when he's doing well he can
just yeah score like between 50 7 to 60
basically every time so I mean I was
kind of prepared for it but you know I
also there wasn't that much I could do
about it I mean I was still scoring okay
not my best but still doing okay but he
just like played better than me in those
rounds so uh yeah I mean it would have
been good if I could have elevated to
like start getting 59s and 60s myself
but I wasn't quite feeling it um as much
today so I think I was definitely
fortunate that um
that he obviously had a lot worse runs
after that but also I'm stayed pretty
consistent and I think when we got to
even I was actually at a big Advantage
because he had more strikes so I knew I
basically probably just need to get one
more one more win to get to four and
with the strike Advantage with the
puzzle uh puzzle Miss Advantage like he
probably lose entire break
mhm what were you doing when you hit
that 69 here that no one has ever
touched in fact even close to it right
so what did you do like what how did
that happen that is still a feat today
that is yet to be
wrong so that was I don't know maybe two
years ago or so that was at a time when
I think most of the more difficult
puzzles like above 40 were
basically um known at least by me and um
probably Jenis also so that's why we
were basically able to get some very
high scores and we were just going for
speed trying to get high scores because
um once we got to the more difficult
puzzles basically they're just about
executing so I think he's highest score
was 67 or 68 then and yeah mine was 69
but it's not the same now there's
there's many puzzles that I don't know
um and uh I think my highest recently in
three minute puzzle Rush was uh 64 so
still pretty high let's see
very nice 60 anything is is quite High I
wanted to ask you uh maybe a general
question um and correct me if I'm wrong
but it seems like watching you and Andy
he has a style where he's a little bit
ahead of you in terms of the pace early
on but you have that more consistent
Style just almost every puzzle feels
like the same to you whereas Andy and
some of the younger competitors man they
can do those first 30 quickly is there
like an ultimate style that you think is
the best for for
puzles yeah I mean I'm used to being
slower than the other like everyone else
in the first minute basically um just
because I really try to focus on not
missing any um but I guess one of the
differences with Andy and probably some
of these other young guys who I haven't
played all of them yet but um even when
I like actually go my full speed uh
they're still like the same or even
slightly ahead of me still so it's
pretty uncomfortable and it's also like
the the higher puzzles I think that's
what really separates him is some people
can be really fast uh in the beginning
but usually when they get to the more
difficult puzzles they struggle a lot
more but he has the ability to I don't
know if he how many of them he knows but
I feel like he actually is solving a lot
of them and he's like incredible at just
the way he plays and from watching him
he's just incredible at solving so um
it's really really difficult and I think
I was really fortunate because I know he
can actually maintain this sort of level
of getting to like 55 plus pretty
consistently when he's doing well so I
was actually pretty fortunate that he he
dropped off um in the last few because
in some of our other matches he's
maintained that level for quite quite a
lot
longer all right we got some questions
from chat Ray questions from chat let's
start with this one from
Oki says
where did you where did the username
spicy caterpillar come
from I didn't come from any particular
Source I think it just came from my
brain uh just a I thought of I mean at
the time I was Anonymous I want to be
anonymous um so I just chose a name that
I liked and and then yeah I just no no
other particular reason okay and
interesting the username questions are
Classics I feel like I get asked mine
like once every couple months so and BB
exactly it's had to make a command in my
stream about it most popular question
I'm telling you well we got another one
for you Ray uh blender again wants to
know you know what felt different in
this Championship compared to other ones
if any you've had so much
experience um yeah this year I guess
there were
um h i mean it's probably closest to the
first year actually that it felt like
there were
multiple matches potential matchups
where I was maybe the favorite but it
really wasn't clear if I would win or
not I think uh I mean especially last
year um things went pretty well for me
but like in the first year there was
Jims and Hans who were both um similar
or close to me and and I felt like I
wasn't sure what would happen and then
this year um I mean I was expecting Jus
again to make it through and then also I
knew how good Andy was and there's other
people like Jeffrey who's very good but
uh also people like pavf who I'd seen
were very good on the puzzle Rush
Theater award but I wasn't sure how
consistent they would be in actual
battles but obviously that was I guess
my I mean in some ways I was even
tougher than the the Andy match but I
mean I guess they were kind of
equivalent because I was I was kind of
in trouble in both of
those chat chat question from C mck fou
says Ray does it help to solve puzzles
to become a better chess player how
important is
that um doing tactics in general is
always helpful especially up to like a
you know a pretty decent level up to I
don't know 2000 or something um when I
was starting out that is the main thing
I did I had these super old chess books
like by Fred reinfeld 101 checkmates or
101 tactics and stuff like that so I
would just like read and reread and do
those puzzles over and over again so
they became like ingrained in my head uh
so yeah it's definitely important in
becoming a better chest
playar very nice Ray want to say again
congratulations it's been five in a row
uh what an achievement and thank you for
your time as well with the interview
really appreciate it
thanks that was Ray Robson James five
times five times I'm going to get tired
of saying congratulations Ray eventually
you know yeah of course I mean it's
great work and you know you get rewarded
for it man all the hard work pays off
five times going through the field and
doing it again and big Ray and have a
nice day is here to
stay absolutely so impressive you see
there the bracket obviously Ray Robson
your champion and uh what a what a match
he had against Andy Woodward speaking of
Andy uh pretty telling me James that
Andy Woodward is also around for an
interview and I can't wait to hear what
he has to say you know the young
competitor just pushing Ray to his
limits ultimately Ray got the win but we
have our runner up Andy Woodward in for
an interview which means we are going to
take another short break but I think
it'll be worth it stick around guys we
got Andy coming up
[Music]
next
excellent
[Music]
you
w
[Music]
yeah
I
[Music]
like welcome back the puzzles World
Championship we just had that epic
conclusion ultimately Ray came out with
the win but we have our runner up here
Andy Woodward Andy I'm going to say
congratulations to you as well because
second place in an event as strong as
this super impressive I'll just ask you
what did you think about Ray as a as a
competitor going up against him in the
finals I mean probably going in you knew
he was going to be the toughest
competition right uh yes um I knew I was
going to have a lot of fun and get a lot
of experience from playing this
tournament and I was hoping to put up a
bit more um a bit better runs in like
the I guess but and ultimately it was
really fun and
enjoyable congratulations Andy great
showing of course you put these 59s and
breaking these records and actually
breaking a record here on uh 59 right
one of your highs there in The Puzzle
Battle uh format so pretty good stuff
man but what goes into the training for
this type of format actually as you in
stream yesterday we were mentioning that
you were playing and we were watching
your games there with Ray there so how
much Puzzle Battle are you you doing
like every day for this type of event um
I guess about like an hour to two hours
practice um during during puzzle week
but other than puzzle week usually about
like two or three rushes a day
so very nice very nice Andy I'm going to
take us back to that that finals there
when you were up 31 you had some 59 59
58 at that point I think a lot of us
were getting really excited did you
start to feel the pressure at that point
any of the nerves cuz look I'm just
going to say it you had some of your
lower scores after that so what was
going through your mind at that point
yeah I guess I was getting kind of
excited and then um that's where it
started going wrong I started like
um mouth slipping and like making pretty
bad mistakes but um I guess that's one
thing to be improved for next year um I
guess the stamina kind of kicked in so
hey James you heard him he said next
year he said next year next year uhhuh
so you going to be here next year that
was our next question so you goingon to
be training what training are you going
to be doing for next year to get ready
for this event because of course you're
going to come back it's going to be
people that want revenge and I'm sure
you probably want some Revenge too as
well maybe against Ray yeah I
guess I'm not really gonna do much
training just everyday stuff for Puzzle
Battle wise maybe a couple training
matches with some friends so
yeah I uh I see some questions from the
the chat here and maybe you'll recognize
this name uh Andy this is from Liam
putam chess he says Andy what would you
attribute your success in this year's
puzzle Championship to did you by any
chance have any special sources of
motivation
um maybe my dad he kept telling me to
keep going and help me only think about
um positive things during the matches oh
that's
awesome mindset very very big on mindset
and positive energy always very nice we
have another chat question Krishna
21234 does age Factor uh into into your
psychology while playing events like
this in terms of nerves confidence and
Etc I guess
I think a little bit because Ray's like
really calm even when he's like losing
and like Jeffrey and many of them
they'll completely calm and um at least
outwardly they're really calm but um for
people like me um once I start feeling
like I'm on the upper hand I start like
um getting excited and then it starts to
backfire so yeah I think it
does wow like Andy some very mature
answers there you seem like a very
mature young uh young man I am very
excited to see more of you in this
puzzle competition I heard you say the
words next year so we'd be very excited
to see you compete then second place in
this event and we can't wait to see more
of you in the puzzle World Championship
congrats again Andy yeah thank you
bye all right James so nice to hear from
both competitors there Ray and Andy I
mean at that age to just be able to
articulate your thoughts so well and
just be such a speed demon in the
competition as well I think he's got a
very bright future ahead of him yeah he
definitely has a bright future 100%
already International Master 14 right so
growing getting stronger playing against
the best of the best even taking it to
to Ray here but Ray was able to Prevail
in the end there but congrats to Andy
because he's gonna be on him for a very
long time yeah he will he will you know
Ray is uh he was even kind of talking
about in that interview like you know oh
it's almost at that point where the
other guys are kind of catching up to me
and you know he was he was feeling a
little bit sentimental there but no he's
still on top for the moment James any
any big final thoughts from you on
today's event the competition and
ultimately our winner do your puzzles at
home of course do your puzzles do them
every day breakfast lunch and dinner of
course do your puzzles is definitely can
uh can help you in your games 100% so
anything from
you do your puzzle I feel like you just
uh enlisted everyone I I'm not gonna add
on to that because I don't think I can
do one better do your puzzles people you
know it's it's a great FasTrack to be a
world champion that's that's what I know
for sure um but while you're doing your
puzzles Andy Woodward definitely doing
his remember tomorrow we got Tada steel
it's creeping up it's uh going to be a
really exciting event I know this one so
nice to start the year and know that
this event is just waiting for you this
is one of the most exciting events for
me on the tournament calendar and it
gets underway tomorrow James I mean we
just did so many puzzles but are you
going to be able to flip around uh on a
dime for some classical chess to to
enjoy actually of course I'm going to be
W I'm full-time chess so oh I will be
watching some Tata steel and ding
playing oh yeah we got to check
everything that he's doing since he's
back in act yeah that's going to be
super exciting so many talents in there
and what a what a couple days and you
were here for both of them James
yesterday today we officially have our
winner for the puzzles World
Championship any final thoughts as we uh
as we sign off for the day congrats big
Ray and have a nice day also had
congrats to Andy too as well nice energy
from chat um shout out to you guys being
here too as well and being here with the
chess bro you know M's always a Vibe bro
it's been great so good stuff man I hope
everybody has a great day and all that
other good stuff so puzzles on the back
end we doing puzzles tonight so see
youall there there we go James I'm
signing off as well guys it's been a
pleasure hope everyone enjoyed the show
puzzle world champion five times it is
Ray Robson that's it from us everybody
have a great rest of your day and we'll
see you for the next
[Music]
Show
excellent
[Music]
h
there
[Music]
he
I like
[Music]
birds
w
[Music]